Trump lawyer Jenna Ellis today pleaded
guilty in the Georgia election case and
a lot of people are uh let's just say
mildly perturbed Jenna Alis raised
somewhere over
$200,000 to fight these charges and is
receiving criticism for in the end just
accepting a plea deal and then
apologizing to the court saying she
regretted everything she did and One By
One The Dominoes fall
this is this is I I have I have trouble
understanding how any of these people
could have taken the position they've
had during 2020 and then just flip in
the way they did but this is going to uh
be somewhat Troublesome for Donald Trump
however he's also filing to have one of
the January 6 cases dismissed on Double
Jeopardy grounds which is really really
interesting as well so we'll talk about
that plus of course you know there's
like World War III stuff happening Iran
is once again attacking us targets the
US is ramping up its forces in the
Mediterranean and there's this really
funny video going around where this
genen Z guy it's it's like he's trying
to say he won't be drafted but then it's
basically him begging not to be drafted
like you want me to fight for this
country I I don't want to do it and it's
like oh boy look I I like very few gen Z
relatively voted but the ones that did
overwhelmingly vote for Democrats so hey
this is Biden country baby at the very
least if you didn't vote for the guy
well I'm sorry it's happening to you and
this is why you got to vote for Donald
Trump but uh let's uh we'll talk about
that before we get started head over
cast brew.com buy our coffee this show
is sponsored by C Brew if you want the
best coffee you've ever had hop over to
C Brew pick it up we got whole bean we
got ground everyone's favorite is rise
with Roberto Jr a light roast but we
also got Appalachia kns dark roast blind
that's personally my favorite if you
want to support the show you can join
the cbw coffee Club you can check out
Cas brew.com also go to
timcast.net uncensored membersonly shows
Monday through Thursday at 10 p.m. we're
going to have one of those for you
tonight and you as a member can call in
submit questions and talk to us and our
guest and get access to our Discord
server which you'll have to do if you
want to submit questions and hang out
with like-minded individuals who create
their own shows and have their own
projects there's a lot of stuff going on
it's really awesome smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and a whole
lot more is Cash Patel hey it's great to
be back with you uh just coming off the
heels of my book launch yes s Swit plug
government gangsters the Biden
Administration spent 10 months trying to
block its release had to go to federal
court and sue to get it out you got to
understand what's in there uh Donald
Trump launched on Truth social a couple
weeks ago already a bestseller he calls
it the road map and blueprint for 2024
basically it's how you destroy the Deep
State and I name every government
gangster I ever encountered by name and
title and I also put the government
receipts in there the Biden
Administration came back and said
National Security Secrets can't go to
Prince they redacted less than
05% of my my book at the end of the day
0 five 05 the same the same seven words
eight times over really it's hilarious
can you not say the words I can after
the show it's kind of funny but like you
know it's hilarious but that's the whole
thing you know and so go to government
gangsters. comom get your sign copy
today help me crush the Deep state right
on yeah everybody buy it we'll get it to
the top it's on Amazon it's on Amazon
get number one Amazon Target all that
stuff yeah really great thanks for
hanging out man should be a blast we got
Hannah clir hanging out yeah hi I'm
Hannah Clair brim I'm a writer for
timcast.net fantastic uh book
recommendation if the Biden
Administration doesn't want you to read
it you should buy it immediately I think
so yeah um I'm with Tim cast news and
Brett's here also yes hello uh I am
Brett dvic I am the host of Pop Culture
crisis Monday through Friday 3m. Eastern
Standard Time right here on YouTube and
I am surge.com I just got a truth Social
account three new truth social users
let's go get mine right now oh there we
go it's about to be Donkey Kong on there
Donald Trump is be bananas on Truth
social social and it's just going to get
better time to rru stuff yeah I can't
wait to do some rru thing anyways guys r
that doesn't sound like propaganda at
all let's jump into this first story
from the New York Times Jenna Ellis
former Trump lawyer pleads guilty in
Georgia election case three lawyers
indied with Trump for trying to uh three
lawyers indied with Donald Trump for
trying to overturn the 2020 election
results will now cooperate with
prosecutors in the racketeering case I
believe this makes four guilty pleas and
Sydney pow got six years in probation
and then the other three Got 5 years
Jenna Alis gets Got 5 years I believe
she also got 100 hours of community
service and fine and pay a fine we have
the video here I'm going to play it for
you let's uh yeah we're going to listen
to what she had to say audio is good
yep thank you your honor for the
opportunity to address the
court oh as an attorney who is also a
Christian I take my responsibilities as
a lawyer very seriously sorry I can't
and I endeavored to be a person of sound
moral and ethical character in all of my
dealings in the wake of the 2020
presidential election I believed that
challenging the results on behalf of
President Trump should be pursued in a
just and legal way I endeavored to
represent my client to the best of my
ability I relied on others including
lawyers with many more years of
experience than I to provide me with
true and reliable information especially
since my role involved speaking to the
media and to legislators in various
States what I did not do but should have
done your honor was to make sure that
the facts the other lawyers alleged to
be true were in fact true in the
frenetic pace of attempting to raise
challenges to the election in several
States including Georgia I failed to do
my due diligence I believe in and I
value election Integrity if I knew then
what I know now I would have declined to
represent Donald Trump in these
post-election challenges I look back on
this whole experience with deep remorse
for those failures of M your honor I
have taken responsibility already before
the Colorado bar who censured me and I
now take responsibility before this
court and apologize to the people so uh
I I hope I hope several other states
file criminal charges against her and
she goes to prison for a very very long
time did you hear what she said she she
confessed to trying to uh overturn an
election a d a duly elected Joe Biden
she confessed to doing it no and all
um I think it's fair to say she's opened
the door legally by stating that in
Georgia and many other states she did
this she did this thing and if there are
other states in which Democrats have any
kind of uh legal capability they could
charge her as well and then make her go
through it all over again the biggest
mistake all of these people are making
in my opinion is taking the plea deals
I've heard a lot of people say the cases
against these individuals in Georgia is
so weak that the prosecutors didn't want
to go to trial and I'm like then you go
to trial M then you say that's the
reason to do that yeah this shows she
was terrified and so I'll say this just
on the service if it is true that she
and many others knowingly lied to commit
this crime then I think they're getting
off easy otherwise she genuinely
believed she was doing her her
constitutional Duty in providing a legal
service uh uh to an individual who's
seeking a Regis of Grievances and now
she is betraying not just that
individual but this country so in that
case lock her up see if I care she'll
get she'll get no defense for me and not
to mention I we'll get into it in a
little bit but like the hundreds of
thousands of dollars she raised a lot of
people are really upset about this you
know what does it mean to give someone's
legal defense she paid her lawyers with
the money does it mean she's taking it
all the way some people were saying she
should take a plea agreement but I'm
curious uh what you think man I mean you
worked in the administration yeah look I
was a prosecutor as a public defender um
the interesting thing about this entire
case I mean put aside the fact that I
don't think there's a basis to bring it
but let's put that on pause for a second
and the first three guys out of the gate
that flipped are lawyers and what does
that mean what did they actually do
having been in the Trump Administration
and around the boss and literally
talking to him every week these guys
didn't really do anything so okay what
are they going to say are they going to
break attorney client privilege which
they don't hold president Trump holds
and say and commit a felony and get
sparred and get prosecuted just to say
Donald Trump is guilty of X Y or Z and
they're not stupid people I think the
reason they pled guilty is they know the
crimes are bogus but they came in there
with so many slews of felonies so it's
like oh you're looking at 85 years we'll
get you on one and this jury pool sucks
it's in somewhere in Georgia that is a
county that is like 88% Pro Biden so
they're going to get convicted so
they're just trying to stay out of jail
pleading to miss demeanor but I would
really like to you know and I also
looked at that's a felony I'm pretty
sure Jenna ell was a guilty to a felony
I'm pretty sure it was a felony and and
I and I cuz I was reading it and I
thought it was uh cuz Sydney pal was
like six misdemeanor and they K they
dropped all she's the first one to go
though I mean they gave her the best
deal yeah I I I want to check because
the story I was reading earlier I'm
pretty sure she was the one that was a
single felony which was uh I thought was
interesting yep yep yep she pleaded
guilty to a felony charge so no more
traveling outside the country luck it's
it's one count of aiding and abetting
false statements and writing and
writings for
stuff she said to the Georgia no no if
you commit a felony and it's in the
favor of the democratic party like Kevin
kleinsmith the FBI attorney lied to the
federal court about CIA documents he got
reinstated to the bar last year and has
a seven figure job now well he's more
trustworthy right so this is coming
along with her book deal and her tell
all and I think it's part of the process
it's why you heard from that White House
intern who made her her lies and
launched her bogus book but this is what
they do the media captures him and says
we're going to launch you to you know
part of me says I don't blame any one of
these individuals for taking the deal
because they all took the deal right it
is a sign of the weakness of the
anti-establishment faction in this
country that they don't actually stand
up for anything and then you look at uh
uh we talked about this this uh famous
makeup artist whatever her name was you
know uh her line is Huda Beauty I can't
remember her last name she posts in
favor of Palestine gets a whole bunch of
backlash and she says I don't care don't
buy my products I stand for what I
believe in I'm like man okay I mean
these these These leftists are willing
to just sacrifice everything yeah for
like their business their company their
money you've got you've got the a whole
bunch of reports of people getting fired
from their jobs they don't care it's
always been this way I mentioned this
with BLM the guy worked at Taco Bell put
on a BLM coid mask and they said you
can't wear that and he goes I refuse to
take it off and they said if you don't
take it off you're fired he goes fine
goes outside films a video and says I
got fired for black lives matter and
then the company apologized oh we're so
sorry what do people on the right do
they take a plea deal what did Jenna
Ellis do she was a lawyer who was
approached by a client who says here's
my argument can you draft this for me
and she goes oh yeah we'll go through it
and we'll advise you on it and that was
it she was she was she had one count
under Rico and one count of I believe
soliciting a public official or
something like that two two charges is
what she was facing and she took a
felony plea deal hundreds of thousands
of dollars and is crying what I what I
genuinely believe is that Jenna Ellis
legitimately thought she was
representing her client in 2020 and is
now terrified and would rather sell you
out you out all of us out and this
country so that she can disappear into
but this is a part of like this is an
established practice if you in Trump
World and you're in Trump orbit and you
get jettison for not doing your job
properly there not only is it a Scarlet
Letter it's an act of Vengeance look at
the the gal that's on the uh not the
Today's Show but the view right that's
one example the other intern that wrote
the White House book as long as you get
jettison from Trump World and are
willing to play ball I guarantee you
every one of these people has a book
deal lined up has a show lined up and is
now guaranteed not to go to prison and
like you said they don't have any morals
they don't have any convictions all they
have to do is just say what they want
and they're going to be famous they're
going to go to Hollywood in LA and
people are going to put them on their
shows and they're going to be the
greatest saviors of America if if Sydney
Powell of all people Michael Flynn's
attorney I I got to remind your audience
Sydney Powell was Michael Flynn's
attorney who helped over turn that case
and and and if if if she of all people
will flip on Trump why would anyone Hold
the Line yeah they they they just
watched It's like being on the
battlefield and watching George
Washington drop his pants and cry and
run from the battlefield I I shouldn't
compare her to George Washington but I'm
saying like a bunch of regular people
are watching Sydney Powell go on TV and
scream and bang her fist and say I will
not back down the viral video of her
saying I will not be intimidated and
then as soon as they're like we're
criminally charging you starts crying
she like please I'll do anything you say
this was a woman who was one of the
people smiling in her mug shot right she
presented
this yeah she presented this this uh
intensity uh to an extreme degree how
can we have a country where we're saying
you know we're anti-establishment you've
got to confront the values here you have
to stick by these things and then you
have these uh people immediately turn I
mean obviously it's what the Democrats
want but in some ways to me it really
foils the motion that Trump filed today
in his January 6th case saying you know
you should dismiss the case because of
First Amendment and Double Jeopardy but
one of the lines in the case was under
the First Amendment Trump and his
supporters have the right to question
and doubt what the government tells them
and so this idea that like she knowingly
Pro promoted false information number
one did she know it was wrong and under
the First Amendment doesn't she have the
right to doubt it I mean it is sad to
see someone who could have argued a
really articulate message in court take
the plea deal I understand that there's
pressure on the other hand if we're a
values-based movement you need people
who are willing to defend their values
the bravado is always so much more so
online than it is
but also like you said like for somebody
like you were talking about the makeup
uh she was a makeup distributor right
she's signaling to her base who's going
to support her anyways but when somebody
who anti-establishment on the right is
pushing back they feel a lot of the
times like they're out on a life raft
once they actually put themselves out
there like that because where is there
to go if it all falls through and they
start coming at you with criminal
charges that you do have to you know
especially if they have a family if they
have kids and stuff like that they're
thinking about what that's going to I'm
not saying that's right wrong I'm just
say I understand where the mindset comes
from where at the end of the day a lot
of these people are going to put
themselves and their loved ones first
over the movement because that's just
hierarchy of needs right for a lot of
them I think this is a direct result of
the two-tier system of justice that's
been built in this country it's one of
my biggest grievances in government
gangsters and it's not just in federal
court it's in state court and what Tim
said was they flipped that's the key for
me as a for okay what did they flip on
but what they're doing is they're going
out to the New York Times and saying oh
we got Trump's three top lawyers and as
a guy from Trump World I'm telling you
these people barely did anything for the
boss and he came out and announced that
Sydney pal wasn't even his attorney so
what they're doing though publicly is
they're saying three Trump lawyers have
now plad guilty to the election fraud
scam case L run by Donald Trump they're
trying it in the public they're trying
to get more and more dominoes to fall so
that when Trump gets to court in in
Georgia finally whenever that is they're
going to say oh 14 defendants have pled
guilty you must be guilty by association
where there's smoke there's fire must be
but where's the evidence because if they
had it this is thing about you know
about the New York Times and these
corrupt prosecutors if they had a
recording if they had you know the I got
you moment the kill shot it would have
leaked this is the evidence no that's
what I'm when when they begin filing
14th Amendment challenges to Donald
Trump's 2024 candidacy they're going to
say the court judge say what's your
evidence Jenna Ellis and Sydney Powell
confessed we have confessions your honor
we have several I mean if they had to
your point if they had in the whole they
wouldn't offer The Plea Deals they would
want every single person to go down for
as long no yeah as a prosecutor I was
like I don't want to you're not going
down for 5 years you're going away for
40 but it me they don't have anything
right your what was the maximum TR like
if she had been if she had gone to court
and in tried her luck what was the
maximum sentence she would have gotten I
think it's probably 20 years because
it's a RICO conspiracy so would they
would they would they would all the
sentences be concurrent not no it's up
to the judge yeah not at all like you
could stack them you can hold she had
two she had two two charges so you can
make him consecutive um so it's a it's a
total crap shoot but that 14th Amendment
thing is just another like hysterical
thing has anyone read the first sentence
of the 14th Amendment I know you guys
have but it says these individuals shall
not and it names the vice president the
Senators the members of the House of
Representatives and lower level offices
you know who doesn't name the presidency
the 14th amendment by its first sentence
doesn't apply to the presidency and we
have all these freaking lawsuits around
the country trying to dispar or whatever
the word is get Donald Trump off the
ballot which is hilarious and this boond
doggle in Colorado I think just uh
forwarded the case on to say oh this
issue is is ripe for uh decision making
because people are talking about it
publicly so uh section three I believe
correct yeah no person shall be a
senator or representative in Congress or
elector of president and vice president
or hold any office civil or military
under the United States or under any
state who is having taken an oath as a
member of Congress or an office of the
United States or as a member of any
state legislature or as an executive or
judicial officer of any state to support
the Constitution shall have engaged in
Insurrection etc etc so vice president
and president are not in here it says
elector of Vice President and Vice
President the president is explicitly
not not in there what do you think the
founding fathers just forgot well I mean
this was Civil War era no I know but
like they would have they were
contemplating what if we have to kick
out these people from office they
contemplated kicking out the president
and they said no that power is not going
in the Constitution I mean that was
their decision hasn't been overturned in
20 so then 50 some years what what where
does this all go I mean Supreme Court I
the all of it yeah but I don't see the
Supreme Court right now side fting
against Trump on this on this matter no
it's not but it's going to take like 3
years I was say how long will it drain
resources yeah that's it I mean look
they're doing it to every like I've
spent $500,000 in attorney's fees on
January 6 subpoenas special counsel
subpoenas I'm just one of the guys I
mean this is what they want you to do
cop a plea bend the knee we'll give you
the book deal you know Cassidy
Hutchinson goes out in the world and
lies literally it's hilarious to me that
her most promising statement of Truth
was President Trump reaching through the
Beast and trying to grab the steer have
you been in the Beast I have there's
bulletproof window between the driver
and the car part of where president
Trump what did she was She Hulk did she
punch through the glass window and how
did she Trump right and how did she even
see it if someone told me that Donald
Trump got really green and big and then
I I have to believe it glass just gets
out of his way they're too scared so
he's the new Chuck Norris they'll just
there's a there's a DI burst it apart
it's like but it is it is hard to say
like if what are you going to take are
you going to take 500 for a lot of these
other people right it's 500,000 in legal
fees minimum or the book deal down the
line and your family doesn't I mean
you're lit talk about winning the
lottery you're getting multiple seven
figures just for lying and you're going
to be glorified in the media the back
end of what we have to deal with is the
if you like look up my name in the media
I might be the Antichrist if you believe
what the New York Times have said about
me but they will just defame you they
will make up stories they will attack
your family death sentences I've gotten
those things at my house every other
month because they they dox me and let
out my personal information I mean this
is what they do to you and the media
it's never end it's never like you that
that pressure never gets turned off it's
it's sad to me that there are PE there
are very few people of conviction that
you know this this when I was reading
this story earlier on my morning show I
just I I don't understand the
perspective of a person who would
purport
to hold certain values and then
sacrifice them at a moment's notice I
understand Jenna Ellis is a grifter
Sydney PA is a grifter this this is what
they are right they said all these
things they didn't they clearly didn't
believe the because the question I have
to ask people is like if if if are you
religious yeah uh Christian Hindu Hindu
uh if you were if you were forced by a
court to renounce your faith otherwise
you go to jail would you do it they go
pound sand I'll go to jail right and I'm
like if you and the reason I bring up
religion is because this is something
that people truly feel as a a conviction
they cannot sacrifice and I'm like to
see people like this go up in front of
TV and be like this is true and this is
correct and then turn around and be like
psych well people who have really strong
convictions are vilified by especially
mainstream media I mean let's look at
Owen Troyer who reported to jail today
right he is someone who has strong
convictions and is treated like a
complete other because of it by
mainstream media if they talk about him
at all and what's being done to him
because there's it's very difficult to
spin his case Jenna Ellis uh this was
her her give s go
and it's been it's it's the archive
because it's been removed she raised
$216,000 this is an archive from earlier
today and it's it's interesting because
there are comments from people saying
she should take the plea deal because
otherwise she's going to burn through
all that money and 200k is not enough to
fight a legal battle like this
especially against any government but
there are a lot of people who are
Furious and they thought that they were
donating to fight the charges not for
her to just instantly C that's the thing
right she came in to be like okay you're
going to be like the here you're going
to be the fact witness in this case that
exposes the corruption of the deep state
in the Georgia state prosecution do you
think they turn on Trump and testify
against them that that's the deal they
have to sign my question is that's in
every plea agreement no matter what
whether what people don't realiz is when
you sign a plea agreement that says I'm
pleading guilty you're saying you're
cooperating in I've done a thousand One
Plea agreements everyone whether you
actually do down the road 99% of people
never do because it never comes up but
the sub sub of question for folks like
her and Sydney poell and whoever the
other person is is what do they have on
Trump like what do they have a phone
call and a recording that you know of
conspiring of words they can well and
this AP news when they they covered it
they were saying you know ultimately
they're going to call into question
their credibility because these people
were participating in what Trump is
being convicted of and so it's easy to
sort of say but you were doing it too
while you're turning on Trump I mean
they're not the Stellar star witnesses
that maybe the prosecution would want
them to be you mentioned these book
deals and these TV shows the only course
of action that Jenna Ellis and Sydney
Powell are going to have is to become
woke leftists well they're on their way
neolibs because they cannot show their
face oh no in in a trump rally oh it
would they get tomatoes thrown at him
boo figuratively they get to be the they
get to be the talking head conservatives
on The View and CNN and and talk about
like Cohen they're going to be like
Cohen oh I was so wrong no it's like you
were talking about you know specifically
these these three people they're in it
for the attention they're not in it for
the convictions it reminds me of like
85% of the people that are in Congress
literally they're there to get rich to
get famous they don't care about their
convictions oh I'll pass this budget
deal today and I'll sell my soul
tomorrow for you because you're a big
lobbyist and are giving me seven figure
payday I mean these people have made a
career in DC out of these boond doggles
and to me this is just a different
extension of that why you might not be
in Congress you are going to get a
golden parachute of monumental
proportions for doing this nonsense but
their their only course of action is
going to is going to be to do go the
Cohen route and be like oh I was so
wrong and I'm I'm you know Trump is bad
all these all these former conservatives
who now acted like orange man bad you
know like the Lincoln project after
2020 they're like the job's not done
we're now going after Republican
Senators and it's like wait wait no
they're just going after children but oh
right but the the the the Lincoln
project says we want to restore the
party of Lincoln so we must remove
Donald Trump and then once once Trump's
out they're like but we're going to go
after other Republicans too and it's
just like right because this is the
grift yeah that's that's the game oh
it's a money-making scam like these
people are getting paid like if you guys
actually knew the amount of seven
figures that is doled out by the Soros
funded boondoggles by all of these
organizations on they are so much more
organized than the Republicans ever will
be I hate to admit but they are and they
just strok in checks I don't understand
I just really really don't the the there
are evil sick twisted people I got to be
honest there's a certain point where
money doesn't do anything for you and
I'm like why sell why destroy everything
around you for something that you
couldn't even really do anything with
like to to to to to elaborate you get to
a certain point of wealth and and I
quite literally mean this speaking from
experience where it's hard to track
things that you're buying and and and
what you're investing in and you hire
people to do it and it's just like for
what purpose does it in it doesn't
enrich your life I mean for for me a lot
of the stuff we do here at timcast is
like investing in in the projects the
missions the people the culture building
things like we bought a building because
we're going to open a coffee shop but
for for people in this in in this in
this world when it comes to news and
politics what for what reason does Nancy
Pelosi need $200 million net worth to
sell out and destroy the country I'm
sorry some people are just evil there
are jobs that you don't really expect
people to make a lot of money in and we
all hear politicians say I'm here for
public service you know the most
lucrative career I could have gone into
the question for me is with these plead
deals they'll run out right we now have
three people who are willing to testify
at a certain point Georgia is going to
want to have a pretty big show of we've
convicted all these people there 15
codend so so let me ask you cash at a
certain point they stop offering plea
deals because they've got they've got
now three cooperating Witnesses who will
testify against the others yeah I think
they keep going only because it's just
it's Free Press every day Donald Trump's
just a little more guilty well that
guy's guilty that girl's guilty she's
guilty he well he's got to be guilty and
then you get 15 people to testify
against Trump and that's your evidence
in in in an Atlanta jury trial which is
like game over if it was a fair Court
where you could go in and cross-examine
these Witnesses and Shred their
credibility based on their past actions
past statements these people have been
on TV on national TV saying the exact
opposite of what they're about to
testify to under oath and you would
destroy them but it doesn't matter it's
like a New York City jury they're going
to be like what and then wake up when
the verdicts do and say guilty MH in
this case too look this is going to go
through the Georgia state court system
then the federal court but the question
is are any of these cases actually going
to get to a point where Donald Trump is
convicted before the next election and
one of these crazy people actually puts
him in jail in prison like one of these
State Court judges says nope you can
have your appeal but you're going in the
CL I I think it's more so to drain his
resources and make it possible for him
to campaign properly well it is I mean
look if you have to be in court and not
on the road but take for instance I
think only what Donald Trump can do and
obviously I'm biased I'm his National
Security adviser but he's in New York
City basically campaigning from the
courtroom yeah like the guy comes out
every 25 minutes and makes a statement
and everyone covers it he's on Truth
social punching out you know hits
against ER Cohen or whoever or the
Attorney General that's true I mean you
know we're talking about these members
of Congress who make all this money and
you said like the most lucrative job
well a lot of the rank and file members
of Congress don't you don't even know
their names they don't make any money
and they're probably there for better
reasons than you got to internet search
the wealth of the member average member
ofg half of them are millionaires it's
crazy but but my point is not every one
of them succeeds in getting attention
and and getting access so for Donald
Trump to be able to walk out of the
courtroom every time they call him in
and get every eyeball in the country I
that's that's something he could not pay
for
are tons of journalists that are just on
Truth social to see what he says well
let's let's let's let's jump to the
story from Tim cast.com Trump files
motion to dismiss January 6 case citing
Double Jeopardy in First Amendment this
is interesting uh former president
Donald Trump has asked the US District
Court of Columbia to dismiss special
counsel Jack Smith's case against him
for his alleged role in the events of
January 6 citing the first amendment in
Double Jeopardy quote if there is any
constant in our democratic system of
governance it is that the marketplace of
ideas not the mandates of government
function functionaries or partisan
prosecutors determines the scope of
public debate stated Trump's reps in a
filing countless Millions Believe As
Trump uh consistently has and currently
does that fraud and irregular
irregularities pervaded the 2020
presidential election as the indictment
itself alleges president Trump gave
voice to those concerns and demanded
that politicians in a position to
restore Integrity to our elections not
just talk about the problem but
investigate and solve it so I think what
they're saying uh here's a quote
additionally as United States Senate has
previously tried and acquitted president
Trump for charges arising from the same
course of conduct alleged in the
indictment the impeachment and double
jeopardy Clauses both bar retrial before
this court and require dismissal is that
true I mean I'm not the Constitutional
lawyer I think on freedom of speech and
First Amendment grounds he should
because if you're not well the two-tier
system of justice again right if you're
Nancy Pelosi hakeim Jeff Hillary Clinton
you can say the election was stolen the
elction was rigged this whole process
sucks I didn't win wah wah wah and then
if you're Donald Trump you're going to
prison so on that just basis Alone by
the way this judge could not be more
corrupt and biased we can get into that
if you want to is that yeah I've
literally been before her um but the
double jeopardy here's a here's a really
crazy thing about Double Jeopardy and I
only know this because I paid attention
for like 7 seconds in law school to try
to pass the bar exam you can be charged
in state and federal court for the exact
same thing it's not Double Jeopardy you
just can't be charged in federal court
twice for the same thing or or the same
state I'm assuming like jur right right
exactly so on Double Jeopardy grounds
he's good if he's saying No this needs
to go because you already are alleging
this in the south Florida case in Miami
uh it's got to go then he's got a strong
point I just these are both Federal then
these are both Federal this has to do
with the Miami DC case and if they're
going to bring more charges or not well
he so in and bringing up um it's
interesting
impeachment is not the criminal case the
the the argument is first they would
impeach Donald Trump then convict him
and then after he's convicted they can
file the criminal indictment and seek to
convict him on criminal charges where in
Congress so so the arguments as to why
Donald Trump can't be criminally charged
yet is that he has to be impeached for
these things first but he's been
criminally charged and right so so the
the argument is uh uh I can't remember
who wrote this um we covered it several
oh I see the legal gymnastics you're
talking about like there's a
constitutional argument that you can't
criminally charge uh uh like like
members of the Trump Administration or
Trump himself because it's it's it's
it's the executive branch you have to
seek impeachment argument
being the president has broad leeway in
in taking actions for the benefit of
this country or the direction of this
country and if you believe the president
has done wrong by this country you have
to impeach him which is the statement of
I challenge I I I hereby accuse you of
wrong High crimes and misdemeanors then
the Senate convicts him for doing it
then after we all agree the president
has broken his oath of office or
whatever yeah you then file criminal
charges against them that's a pretty
good constitutional argument I mean it
makes the most sense cuz cuz what if you
if that was not the case any blue State
could file criminal charges against the
president any time it's state charges oh
the president committed a crime and and
what how are we supposed to have a
president if what like think about the
Civil War when the states were upset
with Lincoln privil War and the fears
about was imagine if if if Virginia or
Alabama was just like H we're criminally
charging the president well you couldn't
that that the argument he has to be
impeached which is the agreement the
president has committed High crimes and
misdemeanors and then is removed from
office more so than just the I'll put it
this way if that is not the standard
then there is no president a single
state could challenge the results of an
election by criminally charging a
president for anything so you need a
federal level impeachment against him
before you can try and criminally charge
him at a state level well you're not
also not supposed to be ever to be able
to charge him while he's sitting in
office so it's going to be even
interesting if he wins 2024 and what are
you going to
do well that's that that's that's that's
exactly the argument uh they're making
is that the actions they are charging
Trump over happened while he was
president in which case I agree with
that he should be immune from that
prosecution because until he's convicted
in impeachment Tri right then U so
totally on board with that because he
was in the white house he was he was
still there saying whatever he was
allowed to say and that's protected but
and and I would I would I would say this
too uh the reason why I have nothing but
disgust for for those lawyers like Jenna
Ellis and cdy Powell is that it is a it
is not just a constitutional duty to
provide legal counsel to an individual
it is not just a legal duty to provide
counsel to someone who is Seeking a
redress of grievances it is an
obligation for Donald Trump if he
believes the election was stolen to
pursue all legal methods to investigate
and and seek remedy that would mean any
lawyer who is taking up that job has a a
duty to this country to make sure that's
the case for Jenna Ellis to have lied in
what in her previous statements that she
believed or that that that she you in
her Arguments for Sydney Powell to have
lied or to have flipped now they are
basically saying the fabric of this
nation means less to them than their
personal Comfort yeah and what you're
also saying is that a president a
sitting president is not entitled to
council is that the precedent we want to
set is that the historical Foundation we
want to set because you disagree with
him politically and that decision should
be adjudicated at the polls and not in
the courts of law are we going to now
when President Trump say he wins in 2024
are we going to go back and arrest based
on this doj's President every Joe Biden
attorney that worked against electing
president Donald Trump and provided
advice to Joe Biden saying it was okay
to take classified documents out of the
you know when you were Vice President
Senator I mean that's what they want us
to do and I think they don't care
because the mainstream media will cover
them and it'll just be orange man bad
but it's a two-tier system of justice
they don't care well uh the argument is
a three- tiered you've got uh the people
who get away with everything the regular
people that get ignored and never get
any attention and then the people who
are arrested for everything you know so
there are a lot of people who have have
talked about going to the police for
help because of crimes and they are
completely ignored M that's true go to
DC is a big reason a lot of this go is
going on that right now given the way
approval rates are sitting are they
worried that undecided voters who are
looking for something different who may
are like look four years have gone by I
maybe you forget a little bit of like a
lot of these people who maybe didn't
vote for Donald Trump in 2020 four years
have gone by things have gotten bad
enough now that maybe they're like maybe
I'm willing to go back to that is the
idea to keep this in the news keep him
in trial not just in an actual trial but
the court of public opinion to keep
voters from wanting to swing back and
possibly give him a shot this time
around because you keep dirtying him up
by keeping them in the news with all
these Cycles well that's the Hope look
remember the Democrats aren't stupid
they're evil and they're Wicked and
they're Geniuses at certain points in
time when they collaborate together they
don't want Joe Biden to be their
candidate they they might not publicly
say that but they're not they're not
morons what they're trying to do is both
dirty up Trump and Biden at the same
time and then they're going to be like
no no we're you know we're going after
both people but they want to give Joe
Biden an exit ramp it's not it's not a
coincidence there are no coincidences in
government major in my book that David
Ignatius of the Washington freaking post
comes out and says oh Joe Biden you've
done so well but please retire now
that's not a coincidence that means the
FBI doj gave David Ignatius the details
of Hunter Biden's criminal case and Joe
Biden's criminal case and said if we
don't get this guy out this is what's
coming and then we're going to indict
him but if we just charge Hunter and we
force daddy Biden to commute his
sentence that's it game over he can't be
president I I I think there's a decent
probability that uh Joe Biden and gets
indicted for the reasons you just
outlined they might have to go to that
I'm saying that's their last option it's
it's it's their but it's their
plausibility shield for middle of the
road uninitiated they'll go to De Merck
Garland who looks like a wet noodle
every time he approaches a microphone
him and him and Chris Ray the worst FBI
director in history will go to the
microphone and said we charge two
sitting presidents or whatever one
former we biased we're not bias charging
Biden too where everybody Biden's a
criminal and I think they Biden is the
sacrificial lamb it it could come I
think Hunter's their leverage point I
think they get to that but here's the
thing they got to figure all this stuff
out in the next 90 days once you get
past the Iowa caucuses they can't air
mail in Gavin Newsome the guy they want
to come in to be president technically
if Joe Biden is incapable of running
it's something something will happen I
mean you're you're right in terms of a
primary yeah uh
but they'll they'll they'll they'll
they'll make it happen you know what I
mean but that's what I'm saying that's
why these articles are starting to come
out from left-wing organizations that's
not random the government has called
them and said hey this is coming we need
you to help us Grease the skids get rid
of this guy politely and then we'll
we'll glorify him for being the Savior
from Trump that's what they will
literally write about him for decades to
come if this play happens and half of
America will buy it that's why I kind of
think a medical issue is the is the more
likely out for Joe Biden well you just
have to watch him on TV for like 30
seconds if you want a medical issue how
do you uh uh how do you get kamla Harris
out of the way how do you get Joe Biden
to not run and how do you get a Gavin
nuan Joe Biden has a medical issue Gavin
Newsome runs out on stage performs CPR
saves the life of the president I mean
think about it and then KLA Harris
assumes the role acting president for
the remainder of the year but then says
I really want to take that senate seat
in California I need to return to my
home no no no she's going to go take her
10 million payday but what you'll say is
I I I am honored to have served this
country as
I took out Trump with Biden the greatest
Victor right and I I believe it is not
in the cards for me to pursue an
election with such short notice so I'd
like to uh honor you know with honor and
humility offer up Gavin Newsome and ask
him to to lead this nation and then you
get a Gavin Newsome that's why new's
probably when when's he he's debating uh
Des on the 30th which is November
November I for for for tater Ron to go
in there and and accept this debate just
shows you the disparity of where these
two individuals you want you want to
know my conspiracy theory is yes I do
but once you know what hilarious for
your audience I go to engagements around
the country for for Donald Trump all the
time and do big events whatever what you
know Ronda sandz should call in for
presidency when he could put more people
a room than cash Patel I mean this have
you seen his events it's sad here's what
I think a year and a half ago we were
talking about Ron being president I mean
tons of outlets were before Trump
announced before he's back in the game
and there was conversation
when Trump was announcing that a trump
disantis ticket would be unstoppable
before disantis I remember being part of
those conversations here's my Conspiracy
Theory special interests who uh uh
establishment interests knew that was
the case probably looked at the polling
data and says Trump's a wild card that
pisses people off but to Santa
stabilizes his numbers by being that
more boring regular politician we need
to make sure they can never form that
ticket so they go to DeSantis whisper
sweet nothings in his ears and and you
and and I wondered this I say it's a
conspiracy I'm not saying it's I
literally believe it's absolute I'm
saying just entertain the the
interesting thought based on this if you
look at what Ronda sanz's campaign has
been like your only conclusion could be
that he is being sabotaged have you seen
him wearing the high heels oh the cowboy
boots with the big lifts big lifts is an
understatement you should have just gone
straight to platforms you know the the
the the front of the boot is flat and
bent like there's no foot in it his it
looks like his foot is pressed up
against the front of the boot and
there's a 4 INT in them now I'm not
saying I know for a fact that's true but
these are the memes that are coming out
you look at how um you know Ashley CL
made a joke about it and Christina Pusha
starts attacking her and I'm like is is
are like are they intentionally nuking
the first thing I said was I believe
that Ron ronda's campaign staff are
secret Trump supporters who are
intentionally nuking his campaign to
help Trump then I thought about it I'm
like maybe the real goal is to stop Des
sandz from having teamed up with Trump
in the first place cuz now that
relationship is is uh Beyond repair yeah
it's nuked it's yeah and I don't I don't
really understand why it would not have
been good for I know there's that whole
thing you know if you have your moment
in politics you don't want to miss it
but would Dan santis have suffered from
being vice president you know I don't
think he would I mean he can't be
Governor again right isn't he term
limited so where does he go vice
presidency is not a bad idea especially
to gain official exposure on the
national stage or you or you give him a
secretarial position in the cabinet
secretary of agriculture whatever right
educationeducation have it out for like
two years or four years and you'd still
only be 46 you know at the time of the
end of the second Trump Administration
you can run in but I think there's it's
not a conspiracy so you got to look at
DES Sis's top three donos Ken Griffin
from Citadel number one he's now
actually conveniently stopped giving Ron
money y but when it first started they
went all in on the super pack and I know
the guys running that super pack they
were always never trumpers and Trump
haters and flipped the wagon as soon as
it became convenient for them and they
were the ones out there in the media
saying we are going to be the ones that
save the Republican party from Donald
Trump and I remember everybody
excoriating Trump for being like you
can't make fun of Ron you can't call him
dis sanctimonious which is not the best
nickname I will say I mean but here's
the effect right whether it was a best
nickname or not Trump's strategy was to
kneecap him before that guy ever got out
of the gate and and everybody in the
political Arena was saying this is not
going to work and Ron Ron literally puts
less people in a room than I do if I
send out one true social it it sounds
like they said if if Trump gets to S us
on the ticket he's goingon to we can't
beat him there's nobody who can run
against them by no nobody and so they
were like let's let's go to to santis
and offer him tons of money and tell him
he's the guy and it's it's his it's his
path convince him and then once he
betrays Trump that's it we're done and
then they walk away and they stop giving
him money isn't he like number five now
already like on the on the what do you
call it the GOP Stakes he's not even
like the second I think he's number
three in the prediction Market but but
you mentioned this the donors have
stopped giving him money they p and that
was a while ago and then he had that
mass layoff like they barely gave him
any money at all it's kind of crazy but
don't worry when he debates Gavin Nome
who by the way will probably clobber him
like you I don't like Gavin Newsome but
he's charismatic he's smart and he knows
how to speak and debate and that's going
to be I'll actually that'll be the one
debate I watch I won't watch any of the
GOP ones uh but I'll watch that one look
at this uh uh Nikki Haley is in second
place in the prediction Market I never
would have saw that coming I got to be
honest she was doing well in New
Hampshire last day checked that's it's
also hard for Ron to push back against
Trump when it comes to like the the
social media presence because he is
supposed to be this traditional
politician that was more of a uh quiet
mind you know quiet fa yeah like so it's
a lot harder in the social media age
when everything's a meme to push back
when people are saying that you're
wearing high heels how do you how does
somebody dignifi you know use dignity to
get their way out of that right so he
said that the the people that work for
him then say to Ashley Sinclair oh
you're you're being rude for doing
something like this when that's that's
not going to work not in the social
media age I mean you'd hope that he'd
lean into the fact that he's young and
be like you crazy kids on social media
with your jokes and your ideas but
instead it was just this crazy serious
thing I mean like he could have gone
boot shopping on Tik Tok and or like on
reals or whatever and it might have been
better but the the it really feels to me
like the undercurrent of what's around
him is looking for a fight and they're
feeling insecure and again I actually
feel like you know I I always say that
we I don't want to short the bench right
like if Trump is elected he will only
he'll be a one-term president and he can
do incredible things but we have to keep
the momentum going there has to be
people after him and so whether it's
Ronda Sanz or not we don't need it to be
this crazy infighting led by people who
are feeling insecure about their
campaign funny too cuz didn't like Logan
Paul did the thing with v and it became
his biggest social media platform to to
push his campaign ideas like Ron
probably would have been better off
figuring out a way to actually lean into
the social media aspect of it like this
picture right here who is that it's I
don't know but like doesn't it you look
at his boots and they're on the ground
but it does look like he's on his T his
tippy toes it's just much more disarming
to people to laugh with them right and
that's that's that's the reality but
doesn't that break his his image right
His Image is supposed to be the person
who uh institutes policy and then
doesn't feel the need to have to clap
back that's what they liked about him
right they like the fact that he was not
the reactionary of trump he did end up
clapping back and he could have been the
guy that is like oh I'm so dignified
haha I'll laugh with you no but you're
right you know you rais a good point
like he could have just waited it out a
hot second been on a meteoric rise and
would have been the dude you know come
2028 whatever that math is instead not
only is he not the dude now he's never
going to be the dude in this generation
like he's 45 so maybe at 65 he could
make a play like Trump did maybe in his
70s but right now he's gone this
Republican party is completely different
the people in the State of Florida have
to everybody's like oh Ron S is doing a
great job in the State of Florida he is
but do you know the vote structure in
the State of Florida in 2022 Ronda
santis got four million votes in the
State of Florida in 2022 Donald J Trump
got 5.1 million votes in the State of
Florida in 2022 or 2020 2020 excuse me
right so when the year they were both on
ticket that's the spread in the State of
Florida he was also losing a lot of the
America first people right cuz they were
like look neocon like they they
immediately smelled neocon on him
anyways yeah and and had a lot of
questions about it so he had a lot he
would have had a lot of ground to make
up there anyways yeah I mean there are
things that and I remember saying this
like at this time a year ago that there
were things that I thought Des santis
could bring to let say a debate stage
and talk about really interestingly I
mean Florida is unique in the sense that
it deals with a lot of illegal
immigrations that's unique to that
region right they have a lot of uh
immigration from Cuba they have a lot of
immigration from oh good homie Sor Ron
Des sanis just sent me sends his team
just sent me a message for a a donor
event in Las Vegas where I live I was
like do you guys even know who you're
sending this stuff to anymore like SC
out are you going to go maybe you know
why not you know maybe I'll go in there
and go walk into Tre ask about his boots
I can ask him about his boots the funny
thing is it's in Treasure Island which
is Phil Ruffin's Place who's not Trump's
best friend I find this hilarious be
like three in heel 3inch lifts or 4 in
lifts just take a picture next to him
cuz we were trying to figure out the and
look and and I and I I was personally
offended as somebody who's short you
know I wanted him to win the short vote
you wanted representation I wanted
representation I wanted him to win the
short vote let's let's jump to this
story from Fox news.com and uh maybe
we'll give Ronda sand a little bit of
Praise here after we just ragged on him
the sandas administration directs
Florida universities to terminate
student chapters that sort support Hamas
terrorist is M now the first thing I
thought when I saw this was this is this
is a misplay this is Ron going too far
in the culture War targeting free speech
from students I don't I don't like that
they support this stuff but we want
these far- leftists to go out and talk
about how they support Hamas and then
you actually read it Ronda santis is
correct in this regard these individuals
are not just speaking the let me read
this the letter States the student group
present in at least two universities in
Florida known as the national students
for justice in Palestine published a
toolkit that refers to the Hamas
operation as the resistance and says
that Palestinian students in Exile are
part of this movement not in solidarity
with the movement quite literally I
believe that's a violation of federal
law in providing material support to
terrorist organizations so in this
capacity it goes well beyond just speech
and it's difficult I always try to be
careful and and and I would I would uh
personally require a lot of evidence and
and adjudication on this
I don't want a government a governor or
president to be able to come out and be
like nope you said you support
terrorists so we're shutting you down
like no no no no we'll bring it to bring
it to court you shouldn't be able to
just just do this they should have they
should have filed something that they
should have to respond to there should
be a uh due process here the letter
explains that it's a felony under
Florida law to knowingly provide
material support to a designated foreign
terrorist organization these chapters
exist under the leadership of the
national students for justice in
Palestine who distributed a toolkit
identifying themselves as part of the
operation a a flood based on the
national SBJ uh JPS sorry support of
terrorism in consultation with Governor
disantis the Student Chapter must be
deactivated these two student chapters
may form another organization that
complies with Florida State statutes and
University policies the two institutions
should Grant these two chapters a waiver
for the fall deadlines should
reapplication take place now my question
here is if they genuinely believe these
individuals are supporting terrorism why
would they be like just refile wouldn't
they be like we are going to arrest and
charge you for this
well what people always forget now
especially is that Hamas is a designated
foreign terrorist organization that has
been the case for decades in Republican
and Democratic um uh administrations so
that's leg one of this whole statute
about you know I used to prosecute guys
for providing material support to
terrorism it can be arms it could be
money it could be planning it could be
whatever right conspiring with them to
do bad stuff so you have that piece of
the puzzle are they a designated foreign
terrorist organization but here's the
thing that's not Florida law federal law
right so anything in Florida that speaks
of that is is superseded by federal law
on material support statutes so you're
right this is I agree that if they're
providing money to a foreign terrorist
organization it's it's material support
what if they what if they claim to be
and are providing labor well then you
have to go to court and prove that
you're providing labor that is not
attributed to terrorist activity right
you're I'm saving babies in you know
wherever and providing food to the home
homeless or something like that so we
get into this we get into this problem
when we have all these humanitarian
refugee camps right like across Syria
and all of these donors want to give
money and you're like well we're giving
it to all these people and known foreign
terrorists who are in the camps that run
the camp how are we going to Pro what
are we going to do with that that's been
an ongoing issue for a long time what do
you think of Tom Cotton he had that he
wrote that letter to meorc saying we
need to expel foreign Nationals who
violate federal law by espousing support
for Hamas because you're not you're
barred from it's it's the law like you
know this doj won't actually do it
because it's it's the doj along with the
state department has to get together to
make that you know ejection possible but
what he's saying I think you have to
break it down a little further than just
expel everyone if you are affiliated
with a known foreign terrorist
organization Hamas in America and you
are supporting them in the very least
you should be kicked out of the country
and more likely prosecuted what normally
happens you get prosecuted then you get
stripped of your citizenship or
residency status then you get the boot
do you think any of this is likely to
happen though that's what I find to be
the crazi thing there's going to be all
of this Fury and the progressives
themselves are divided over the issue
but nothing will happen from the Biden
Administration not this one and stuff
like this is going to become more common
in the internet age as these people are
able to coordinate more freely I assume
well like look so the difference between
Al-Qaeda and Isis I mean the main
difference right Al-Qaeda they brought
your self and your team to wherever Stan
mountain region they were to train you
up kit you out and send you back out to
do your thing Isis just did it online
that was their deal that was their that
was their whole recruitment platform you
don't need to come to you know
Afghanistan or Pakistan where click here
and donate click here and learn how to
fire an AK-47 and then eventually maybe
you'll come down range and go to one of
our camps so that's already happening
and our problem has been you know it's a
free speech thing what if these guys are
in these chat groups or in these you
know Pro Isis organization chapters and
they're saying well I just support what
they say I don't support what they do
it's it's it's hard to prosecute that
it's hard to make that call and it's
hard I think for a lot of like the Free
Speech Americans who do believe in that
like especially because a lot of them
were younger right a lot of those Isis
those kids who got involved with I was
like in Minneapolis or whatever like
those were they were like barely out of
their teens mean a lot of the one of the
arguments I hear all the time is that uh
especially with the like first
generation Americans whose parents are
you know of one culture and you're kind
of torn between the two they look for
identity online and become radicalized
and so that's a very difficult and sad
story to pedal on the other hand you
know ultimately if the conclusion is
radicalization you have to treat that
really
seriously yeah it's not fun I waited
through a lot of those cases it's but
you know people always forget you're
like we focus on designated foreign
terrorist organizations right because
that's the federal law material hook for
material support and it's not like we're
just going after the KKK right like
obviously I hate those guys but most of
what they say is protected Free Speech
their right to even organiz oriz and
convene together is protected on their
constitution that's the way it should be
right but there's a separation between
what the KKK does and what Isis and
Al-Qaeda and Hamas and all these other
organ Hezbollah all these organizations
do you know you're talking about people
who have done so much destruction to
American and American Allies that the US
government was like you're you're on the
list for Life yeah um that's it there's
like almost no getting off of it yeah I
wonder what you think of uh the
organizations that are uh saying you
know they won't hire these students from
Harvard I think lar Hogan just did that
because some people say you shouldn't
cancel them you shouldn't do like there
is an argument that that's not fair on
the other hand like if you're hiring
someone and they advocate for you know
terrorist organizations that we have
recognized since like what 1997 that's
pretty serious well first of all all
these all these institutions are private
they can do whatever the hell they want
they could hire whoever they want they
can come out and say we don't want
Harvard guys who had done XY or Z they
could have done that so is it different
when Larry Hogan says he won't hire from
Harvard well if he's saying that as well
he's not governor anymore so I don't
know where he's hiring these people but
if he's hiring them for government jobs
somewhere then that that's going to be
an issue but if if even if like say JP
Morgan right the world's largest bank is
like yeah we're not taking anybody from
Harvard because of this nonsense okay
what are they going to do it's totally
within their right to say that no we're
going to hire murderers do you think it
will change how
Academia those guys are too I mean
that's what I always think that they're
sort of lost institutions so yeah but a
lot of these students started writing
letters being like no no no no no we're
so sorry we didn't know and then you got
people coming up being like these
students really didn't know it was in
the letter we should uh be nice to them
a lot of these students are Marching uh
they they they've not changed their mind
these students go to Harvard they're not
stupid they well they are Harvard that
would be right that would be their
knee-jerk re you know argument I went to
I League school I'm a brilliant person
is that a worse indictment that like you
go to Harvard but you didn't read you
you were signing like that's that that
might be it's like I'm not hir I'm not
not hiring you because you said you
support Tomas I'm not not I'm not hiring
you because you didn't read you didn't
read the damn paper right like how or
you're lying that you did read it and
now you're trying to be like oh no no I
misunderstood either way all of those
are very bad yeah it's not great it's
just going to get worse I I think it's
all connected like those institutions
like Harvard yeah whatever any AV League
school is connected to this entire
pipeline movement that we've been
talking about when these people flip
when these people write books when they
go on TV when the who's the person that
just went got kicked out of somewhere
and is now like the uh professor at uh
at Princeton or or Yale this just
happened to uh I'll think of it anyway
you get rewarded they're part of the
reward system we're going to be make you
president of this institute we're going
to contct what's funny about this
there's a voice actress named Tara
Strong and uh she's the voice of like
Timmy Turner and Batgirl Harley Quinn so
a lot of people who are familiar with
like DC Comics and and cartoons have
heard her voice Sho was on Drawn
Together on Comedy Central she got fired
from a show because she was tweeting in
support of Israel so the show abruptly
tweeted out that she would no longer be
voicing one of their characters and then
she starts losing it like I'm being I'm
finding out from the internet I'm being
fired for being Jewish things like this
but what I find fascinating about many
of these people uh Tara has me blocked
right because she's one of these woke
leftists and despite the fact that we
always calmly and rationally tried to
explain to them that these the LM and
the far left want the eradication of
Israel they plug their ears and say
you're far right you know blah blah blah
and then the Reckoning comes for them as
as as we've been warning about for so
long these people who think they can
keep their head down and just s the left
will be left alone they that's not true
she gets fired because of this unless
you have no opinions whatsoever like
literally you would have to have no
opinions whatsoever because eventually
no but then they you're staying quiet on
this issue you're staying quiet on this
isue why do you comment on it that's
what happened if a ramas Swami exactly
they kept demanding he keeps speaking up
and he was like I did they're like more
and he's like I've had it this has been
like the number cuz we we' just been
talking a lot cuz everyone of the all
these celebrities have something to say
about what's going on right now like
you're not involved in this like you
don't need to have an opinion on this
stuff doesn't benefit it's all of their
publicists that have something to say
who are saying you really really need to
tweet about this let me let me pull up
this story from rollingstone.com oh boy
Hollywood stars musicians call for
release of Hamas hostages in letter to
President Biden you know what the the
letter is basically saying it's it's
saying Jo Biden declare war on Iran okay
but let's read they say scores of
Hollywood actors musicians Comedians and
other entertainment figures signed an
open letter to President Biden on Monday
calling for the release of all hostages
Hamas has taken among the hundreds of
signatories were Amy Schumer Jerry
Seinfeld Jus Timberlake Madonna Katy
Perry Bradley Cooper the letter is part
of a campaign called No hostage Left
Behind which seeks the release of more
than 200 hostages taken during the Hamas
attack on
Israel now my question is what is the
ask Hamas has hostages so you wrote a
letter to Joe Biden it's simple they're
saying go to war and do whatever you
have to
do the anti-war party is saying go to
war and do whatever you have to do you
know having run counterterrorism for
president Trump and the hostage
portfolios and bringing home 54 guys we
kind of know how to do it and this this
this Americans have been taken Joe Biden
has brought home none of them the qari
government has brought home four
Americans wow four yeah and this this
warmongering machine the Liberals are
saying yeah let's do another Afghanistan
Hollywood hasn't been anti-war in a long
time they've been anti-American for a
long time uh and pro and pro-islam
during uh Iraq and Afghanistan lots of
movies bear that out but they're not
anti-war not not in any sense of the
word and right now the I think it's
worse than that for a lot of this I I
don't even know if it's so much that
they think that far ahead I think that
they just know that these are issues
that they need to have an opinion on
because their public Persona requires
them to be seen and heard talking and
it's a way to stay relevant they have to
be on it it's ridiculous I mean if you
actually about anything like this would
you make it so like I need my I need to
post this tweet so people engage with it
so they see that I'm empathetic I mean
it's really ultimately narcissistic and
about themselves I wonder though if
Hollywood uh how much of Hollywood
acknowledges that they're not antiw war
anymore it's the same thing with the
Democratic party being like we're
countercultural and you're like no
you're not you you are the mainstream
force and you Market this all the time
and yet you claim that you're sort of
this weird Underdog when you're
obviously not their brains don't process
that at all they still believe that
they're the counterculture they still
believe that they're the party of
anti-war they also believe that they're
part they're the party of the of the uh
the little guy rather than the party of
big banks in in big money but for a lot
of like I've watched every one of these
celebrities have the most artfully
written response that's supposed to
appease both sides only to watch them
one by one get taken out instantly
because they don't realize I think a lot
of it is not being fully in touch with
your audience it's like they don't
realize the size of their platforms and
just how actually diverse the amount of
people yeah you're going to get soccer
moms who like your stuff but you're also
going to get young leftists you're going
to get they don't realize that no matter
what you say it's not enough it will
never be enough because the most vocal
of either side will come at you no
matter how neutral you remain the best
thing you could do is not say anything
but they are too addicted to the
attention and they need the and they
need the rub and they're self-important
they think the world needs their opinion
which is challenging I mean it's similar
to a lot of uh politicians who weigh on
an issues that they're actually probably
not that well versed in but they're
saying you know if I don't get the right
Buzz out then no one will pay attention
to me again it's Des I mean you were
talking about this before they
ultimately all want the attention and
that's why I think people fight so hard
to stay in office right I mean the fact
that Diane Feinstein stayed in office
until she was actually dead is crazy I
mean that is not wanting to give up
power I well it's power and relevan all
worth like aund some million dollar it
was like a billion she married Crazy In
Like A they were like private jet and I
mean she married a crazy wealthy guy the
other thing is like so in the weeks
leading up to her death she had to sign
over uh Power of Attorney to her
daughter because there's all kinds of
legal disputes over the estate and they
said you know she's really sick this
past year she shingles and some
complications from that and so she needs
the the money for her medical bills I
mean it's it's such a strange thing
where we're having someone who can't
fight their own legal battles but can
still be brought to and from uh Nancy
Pelosi's daughter was pushing her
wheelchair around Congress but she
didn't need to retire no worries she's
going to stay our country is sick that's
disgusting this is the thing like I I
when Josie the redhead Li is here she
was saying she would want Ron Paul to be
speaker of the house and I love Ron Paul
I think he's great but he is elderly let
him just rest and hang out with his kids
and write interesting books but do not
make him do this dumb bureaucratic job
in Washington until he dies like this is
not the culture I want and they are the
ideological children of Ron Paul that
are available Dave Smith exists like
Dave Smith make him speaker of the house
and then we are again expanding this
bench of people who can potentially Le
the country in the right direction let's
just not make Ron Paul work until and
meanwhile Mitch McConnell needs to be
rebooted every 15 minutes when he's
giving a speech maybe should the fact
that M Romney is the first person to be
like I'll be in my 80s I should step
down it's like the first sensible thing
I've ever heard from him in my life I'm
I'm going to throw Game of Thrones
reference out there you know this is
this is the circle this is the wheel
that continuously spins and Donald Trump
was the force that broke the wheel he
broke it for a while and robbed all
their people of the Rolling Stone
headlines robbed these people of these
important jobs and TV interviews and
positions exploited them for the corrupt
actors that they are I mean the Insiders
trading alone between Pelosi and
Feinstein should be enough to send them
to prison for an eternity got to get
that Pelosi Tracker out no get the it's
called unusual whales or something like
that
I follow all my all my if you want to
invest in stocks just look at unusual
whales CU they are they are literally
citing the upcoming legislation that
these guys are betting their gambles on
and they track it all and you can go
probably like 5 to 7% return on there um
but they figured this out and now it'll
probably spread where they'll be like oh
most Americans have figured it out so
you know we're going to make this
illegal but they need they still make
money right so they're still going to
keep doing it that's why that's why
Congress does never going to write
themselves into a law that says oh well
we can't of course not of course not
Matt Gates and AOC teamed up trying to
stop them from doing the younger
generation is saying like hey wait maybe
this isn't great it's like telling them
to introduce term limits but but I think
I'm optimistic I'm optimistic because if
you look at Matt Gates the reason he's
able to do what he does is because his
donors are individuals on the internet
that he's got small donors he doesn't
need to go to one man for a million
dollars he can go to a million men for
$1 and women no you're so look whatever
you think about Matt and I've known Matt
a long time about whether he's right to
start this process or wrong to start
process no no I'm just saying whatever
your position is I agree but I'm saying
he was the only one that I know of that
could go to The Well of the floor in the
house of the representatives and announc
to the world that I have not
accepted1 from one lobbyist or one
defense industrial complex organization
mind you Matt has one of the biggest Air
Force bases we have in his home District
wow so for him go out and say that and
then the chorus of booze comes in and
his response to me was perfect every
single one of those people booing took a
six and seven figure paycheck to their
super packs maxed out donations parties
in DC had them on their Jets and their
planes and they were caught red-handed
with what Donald Trump had caught them
with being the biggest Hypocrites who
are in charge of running our democracy
and I think he's excoriated for it now
because we're in this position where
we'll probably just have Tim P become
speaker but we'll get to that uh we're
in this position where you know they're
like it's a rudderless government I was
like how How well was it steered when
McCarthy what do you you were on the ver
you kick the dead ceiling you were going
to give us another CR these oversight
investigations that were supposed to
promise the you know the end of time um
were running we were being run by wet
noodles and you weren't empowering them
to enforce their subpoenas and now we
have an exposure I think it's a big
Civics education you have people paying
attention of course the left's going to
come and be like the Republicans are
ruin Governor but
hey right now they they can't pass a CR
or an Omnibus because they're speak they
can't fund a war either they can't fund
a war they can't write a check to the
Ukraine no there I'm seeing I'm seeing a
lot of these conservatives on Twitter be
like what did we really gain from Matt
Gates's stunt and like why did he do
this and I'm just sitting back like you
know all the Libertarians are laughing
because now there's stagnation and
there's no more wasteful spending
because they can't they can't write a
check it's not what we gained it's what
zalinsky lost dude have you even heard
of that guy like him no he is so mad
about it he's begging he's not happy
being the side piece no no I remember
after all the stuff like after the
October 7th uh stuff happened in Israel
he was like putting on statements like
yes we too have suffered don't forget
that we in Ukraine we need some money
here it's that it's that friend who like
every time something bad happens to you
he's like yeah something worse happened
to me you know what would be a good way
to get Ukraine and I'm not saying
there's people over there that don't
need help and obviously Russia's
attacking a lot of zones but when you go
on the interwebs and you type in like
Kiev nightclub it's like Miami Beach
have you seen these freaking parties
like my friends have gone over there do
a bunch of work over there and they're
like what war zone like what are you
talking about you can't have that going
on and ask the world for $500 billion it
is funny because I I have like friends
that skate in both Russia and Ukraine
and if if you're a hockey guy no it's
well I mean hockey too but it's it's uh
skating is like aggressive SK but like
like like if you if you were going by
their social media post like their story
posts it's like the ones who are in
Ukraine are posting about fundraising
for their go you know fundraising for
the military but then you see their
posts and they're just out skating at
the skate park and I'm like how is that
happening right now no no no this this
is something people don't get I talk
about a bit uh uh people don't
understand that countries in war are not
every every every place in this country
is at war war know about but I I I this
is the story everyone's heard me say at
nauseum in Egypt during the second
revolution two blocks away from T Square
where the revolution is taking place
there's a guy at McDonald's watching a
soccer match like there was a casino in
the Hilton Hotel you were not allowed to
enter if you were an Egyptian citizen
because it's it's what's the word is
Haram the right word like it's it's a
violation forbidden but uh tourists were
gambling in there playing roulette crabs
Blackjack yeah of course two blocks away
from a revolution where Apache
helicopters are flying over and there's
apcs people are shooting at each other
in the streets and blocks away no nobody
cares and and these things become
normalized right I mean think about the
protest in parisis here there were so
many videos of like these people having
dinner at like whatever cute little cafe
and meanwhile something's on fire and
someone's throwing something through a
window like if if you've been in
Conflict for a year at a certain point
you know someone's not going to keep you
from the bars what was the video of like
the girl doing like a Tik Tok dance
while a military coup is going on behind
her oh that's on myar that's actually
Burma yeah there you go that was she was
actually a yoga it was like a yoga thing
or something like that it's even better
you know her you call
no no no it's just like it was great cuz
very current
year I mean especially I know Tim is is
feeling imp passionate about this
subject uh if that conflict has been
going on for actual decades keep you
just live with it yeah eventually all
right I'm going to Let's shatter some
hearts oh you're going to do it here we
go from the New York Post UFC partners
with Bud Light as embattled beer tries
to fight off Dylan mulany backlash I
don't understand this
I'll I'll break it down very simply Bud
Light they having a meeting being like
okay everybody's calling us names and
saying we're weak and effeminate and gay
and whatever we need to sponsor the
manliest thing imaginable how about MMA
they go to UFC I bet the first phone
call they had with UFC UFC is like are
you joking and wa wait wait wa wait
don't hang up don't hang up we'll give
you $100 million and they're like that's
not a lot of money to UFC though that
starting bid starting bid I mean you're
right I'd like to see what the price tag
was end it's like UFC is owned by
Endeavor right so Endeavor is this
massive conglomerate that just bought
WWE as well so they own both of these
companies it's all R Emanuel it's a100
million wouldn't even move the needle
for them and I just want to say I know
we were critiquing people for not
standing by their values at the top of
the show um I thought we were trying to
get rid of the fratty culture around uh
uh around bud you know let me read this
and eer Bush and budlight were UFC's
original beer sponsors more than 15
years ago I'm proud to announce we are
back in business together Dana White
said in the statement there are many
reasons why I chose to go with anheiser
bush and Bud Light most importantly
because I feel we are very aligned when
it comes to our core values and what the
UFC brand stands for I'm looking forward
to all of the incredible things we will
do in the years ahead what he's really
saying is bro the paycheck was huge you
would not believe all the zeros vers
fall and fox will go on this year the
values they share are the amount of
zeros on the back of the check so many
zeros you cannot the values he's
referring to our monetary values Mones
right I don't know this is a good
picture too where he's just like look
guys just to say they had to make a
longer check there was so many zeros I
mean Bud light's gonna do whatever Dana
White asks now right is Dylan mulany
gonna be the card girl or whatever no
there's no way that they they repartner
with Dylan mulany but but I I I this is
what what what did budlight try to
sponsor Harley-Davidson it didn't work
worked dud they really think I I got to
be honest I'm I'm willing to bet there's
a lot of MMA guys who are going to be
like f no yeah they're gonna be this is
here's what I imagine you're going to
hear like press conferences with some
Fighters and they're going to rag on
budlight it's going to it's going to be
worse for budlight by trying to do this
for whatever reason MMA guys tend to be
particularly based as it were or
redpilled have you seen the entrance
that Donald Trump made at the last UFC
fight in Vegas Dana White and Mark wber
both said they've never heard anything
like that do you think do you think
Donald Trump is going to walk back down
hand inand with Dana White holding a
freaking Bud Light like you're right
those Fighters I know a lot of them you
I live in Vegas my buddy has one of the
most successful MMA training centers and
owns like half the fighters in in the
UFC these guys are not going to tolerate
this and they have massive social media
following but it's it's not just about
even personal conviction if if you're
someone with a with a big presence and
they're they're telling you to stand in
front of a Bud Light you know Marquee or
whatever you're going to be like no I'm
going to get roasted are you nuts but
then they're going to say oh you're
under contract so you got to do it's
going to it's GNA it's going to get
weird yeah but MMA dudes are not the
kind of guys to be like no a contract
they're the kind of guys going to be
like I'll rip it up in front of your
face there's no second UFC like they
can't be like I'm switching leagues and
I'm going over here right they they have
it's all owned by the one thing there's
there's there's the UFC there's the pfl
they're all owned by the one look look
there you you look at all these
industries we we're talking earlier
about like Jenna Alis pleading guilty
and they're all caving and bending the
knee UFC not even just just MMA in
general has a very high density of
individuals who will tell you to shove
it yeah but I think it's kind of obvious
like these are guys who work really
really hard they're top level athletes
but they're also very very capable
people who are not worried about what
you think you can take from them yeah
I'm wondering how many MMA fighters go I
don't really care about that you
probably get some what's like the big
UFC chat space I would love to see what
they're posting already some of these
top fighters like if you look up the top
like 10 fighters to see if any one of
those guys have put something out on uh
on uh Dylan I can't believe this is a
headline what would their contracts look
like though like if you know if it
wasn't Bud Light it was a monster or
whatever like they not allowed to
disparage the brand like what what does
it look like there's usually non likee
disparagement Clauses or like you have
to like wear the shorts like are these
guys going to walk in with Bud Light on
the floor of the of the Octagon well
it's a big sponsorship also it's going
to be such Terri Optics like these guys
grappling on the ground over Bud Light
like I don't like it that's gross I just
picture these Optics like you have just
taken a monster defecation on budl for
the last there is also there's a large
proponent of that industry that's going
to be very Normy that isn't going to
know what's going on with the with the I
think that's what they're betting I
think they're trying to I think there's
plenty of nor I think that we fall into
a little bit of of tunnel vision here I
will say the Bud Light the budlight and
the target back-to-back boycotts were so
big I mean I know non-political people
who are really mad about this and so
they are gambling that yeah both of them
but the the thing is they're gambling
that these these issues from earlier in
the year have been memory hold and I
just don't think that's the case I think
especially with the people in this
particular industry they remember they
oppose it I mean no and the UFC World
RIT large I mean you got to you you're
right I think in any other sports it
would be diluted but the UFC world I
mean you got to pull up the video of
trump all of those people went there1
million
no way that's I'm pretty sure I mean
well I'm I'm looking at tweets they're
all in on it there was people are
tweeting $100 million maybe the most
hilariously dystopian thing I saw this
year I was watching like during the
playoffs for baseball there's like a
giant locki Martin sign bind at like in
in center field during the Astros uh it
was just yeah $100 million and how much
stock does Dana White personally own in
in Bud Light like if it goes back up
what does he get my understanding is
that if he bought stock in anheiser Bush
before this deal that's insider trading
but what if they gave it to him as part
of the deal right you know what I mean
so now yeah well actually no not him
individually so if it's a $100 million
deal if they cut him in on the side I
think that's also insider trading yeah
I'm just wondering cuz like if that does
seem low $100 million doll so I have to
assume that he is personally profiting
in some way like I I buy that the people
that are there live at the event would
would be that way they ditch Modell yeah
they did we like
yeah we do
wow that's crazy we were like it's the
biggest sponsorship in UFC history
targets the next one guys I tell you
like he said we share a lot of values
and that value is monetary yeah true I
mean Bellator is probably excited about
this they're definitely get some
Fighters going to be like ah screw this
I'm going to go to bellor yeah yeah
you're right yeah honestly yeah so
that's the thing if they have an
alternative you're potentially losing
good fighters to that it just depends on
how like that's why I want to know about
the contracts if they can't get out of
it they have to they're all own by the
same UFC and pfl are all the same but
they're not going to have to wear like
the jerseys or the shorts if they change
you know what I mean even if it's
ultimately own well who's going to be
the first guy to wear budlight uh
fight bu short you're going to get M to
to high hell I can tell you that but I
really like said the same owner they're
just going to go to the other the other
bouts why would they why would they s
around if they're the only ones
sponsoring Bud Light and let's say
Bellator isn't then why would they just
go fight Bellator yeah maybe the the cat
I guess the money's different the money
the pot's different yeah the cut is way
less but would it change if more people
were in the league yeah that's what I
mean what if all the viewers are like
I'm not going to watch UFC anymore
because of this yeah forget this Trump
fraud stuff tell us about this you'd
have to upend like you'd have to get all
the tier one Fighters out of the UFC
dump them down into the pfl and Bellator
where most of the amateur fights are and
you'd have to reorient the I mean Dana
White owns it so well he they own it but
Dana runs it they're not going to change
what a multi-billion dollar industry um
I mean maybe if this budlight thing
backfires but um 100 million just seems
small I I don't know why it seems it
seems small to me for that type of that
type of investment so maybe they really
do share values and that's terrifying
right what values are we getting from
Bud Light right now man timcast could
have sponsored it for that kind of money
yeah no way you don't want you don't
want to have your face on all of the
UFC's uh jerseys and stuff yeah if I had
$100 million geez know anybody no I mean
Bud Light if Bud Light Came to Me and
offered me $100 million I would say no
this is what I was talking about earlier
with like these corrupt people in
Congress that make all this money
I'm like I don't I don't I don't
understand it I mean at a certain point
like maybe it's just like a leftist
worldview I don't know at what point
does budlight try to get on Public
Square that's what I really budlight is
like please Michael in five in five
years when Public Square is bigger than
Amazon and anyone who's not on that
platform is is struggling to get sales
because they're considered Fringe and
weird budlight then apologizes and
pledges to support American values and
family values and you could never trust
them you could never trust them to do
any of Tucker just putting a million on
Public Square a Public Square put a
million on Tucker yeah sorry I know it's
amazing a smart move a brilliant move
Tucker's got a massive show with a
massive presence and now Public Square
gets the sole sponsorship for a million
bucks it's a good deal for them it's a
great deal I mean Public Square is is
the most important uh uh culture War
business and application right now you
download an app that shows you the
businesses that agree with your values
that's it yeah no question it's
incredible and it was it it's so amazing
that Michael saw the need and filled it
I mean that's what I wish more people
were theyve had a rough ride though they
came in high and it's pretty down right
now in the in the stock world do you
thinking yeah they came in at like 30
they're at like five now Public Square
is well that's normal though like that's
a big drop from an IPO inside of a year
yeah but Facebook went from like what 45
to like nine you're right it it's it
that's why everyone's always like be
careful when buying it an IPO because it
always drops off they sell they sell it
they dump a whole bunch and it falls
down yep yeah but you know it is what it
is my concern
is is how are we winning the culture War
and what are we doing and we had we had
Carl Benjamin on the show and he was
like the right's not organized not doing
anything and then I'm like Public Square
does this and his eyebrows go up and
he's like oh that's actually brilliant
yeah and there are there are companies
out there they just it's hard to break
through there's a lot of companies that
see this the world that way there's cell
phone companies there's coffee companies
there's payment processing companies all
these people do it it's just it's a
beast to get someone already super
chated saying they cancel their UFC
Fight Pass subscription o it is also
hard keep going a lot of these like if a
if a larger company then offers you a a
ton of money Jeremy's Fighting
Championships JFC JFC I got I'm I'm
going to text Jeremy boring right now
and be like bro can you launch an
MMA his brand is crazier and crazier and
they all have the chocolate bars with
them like I'm imagining like his
assistant runs into his office right now
and they're like they're like Mr boring
Mr boring and they hold up the paper and
he's
like wait does this work or does this
not work he's like who here's in the
best shape we need to film an ad right
now yeah what do you think does this
take for UFC does this work or does this
not oh no I think they're I think
they're going to eat it well look no
matter what happens there is going to be
controversy the fact that we're even
talking about it and people are saying
they're cancelling because of it there's
already controversy it may not be that
big of a deal because the average person
who watches
MMA or whatever might just be like dude
I don't care about that stuff I want to
watch the the champion fight the champ
fight the the you know the the contender
or whatever and so we'll see but I I
kind of think a lot of UFC guys are very
vocal politically they don't care like
they they believe what they believe and
they are not weak people yeah like it is
a high density of individuals that are
in MMA that are just like I will say
what I believe screw you I don't think
it'll be the boycott that we saw with
Bud Light itself because Bud Light you
can pick Alternatives right if there's
really no alternative USC there are
people who are like look I like this I
work hard I want to watch the fights
like I'm not going to buy are they going
have other beers there I don't know so
so when this was going down I went to I
I spent a lot of time in Nashville and
and I'm a big country music fan and I
went to uh a Luke Holmes concert out in
in Titan Stadium like you know 55,000
people and they were still under
contract with Bud Light whoever was
putting on that that show when I left
the
arena I couldn't find when I walked in I
couldn't find one person holding a can
of Bud Light they were drinking
everything else that they could get
their hands on when I left the arena
there were truckloads of Bud Light
stations around the arena that had not
sold like more than 3% of their beers I
mean they were just stacked to the
ceiling so if they did that in country
music in Nashville like it's not a far
stretch that they don't buy their stuff
here now I guess it doesn't
matter what what happens if a fighter
comes out and and right when he comes
out he goes don't buy Bud Light
somebody's going to say that know
somebody some dude is getting up and
saying that and and Bud light's going to
be like wow this made things worth
actually made it worse there's a massive
fight in Madison Square Garden in two
weeks UFC is going there and um
supposedly there's going to be some
appearances from some celebrities like
Dylan molan oh interesting so we'll see
how this sh we're going to know how this
shakes out I'm telling you in like two
weeks it's just they they budlight has
had a marketing catastrophe since this
started and they've never figured out
what to do about it because they could
have just apologized yeah we got it
wrong see you later sorry guys we this
was an you know a young marketing
Millennial we we we we apologize we're
not going to do it again instead they've
been double they've been trying triple
quadruple down oh they've been
sponsoring Pride events but then all of
what was this the gay bars in Chicago
were like we're not buying that beer
you're not supporting Dylan malany
enough y they got double out that's
right and all of the leftists who
weren't buying it anyways are just going
to not buy it anyways cuz they weren't
buying it in the first place it it was a
dumb move and like I said they their
their marketing executive said that
thing I came in to to fix the fratty
reputation I'm sorry but I learned about
UFC with guys who were in fraternities
that they were the ones who were playing
it every Saturday do you think that this
isbg like that's this has become every
marketing department in a lot of
American companies now is they're
chasing this Phantom audience that they
believe that they can expand their
portfolio on right they think that
there's this magical group of happen in
comics it's happened in films and they
always think there's this magical group
of people first of all they don't have
money the people that they're actually
looking to buy stuff for they're not
they they don't have money anyways and
they go looking for it and then they end
up destroying their own market share by
insulting the people that they actually
make the profit uh make it for in the
first place but then these guys come in
on the other side I don't know if you
saw I can't remember the name of company
it's like conservative be or of America
or
whatever Ultra right Ultra
righted Ultra right like now it's like
$2 million or something yeah well that's
why I said Jeremy's Fighting
Championship or whatever whatever you
stands for uh Jeremy boring got a
chocolate bar company we got to order
more of those by the way everybody
really loved them but people didn't like
the one with nuts they like the ones
with no nuts cuz it's it's he him she I
want her to make a dark dark chocolate
bar that's what I'm waiting for I'm sure
that name won't be offensive at all I'd
love to see what it comes up with it'll
be fantastic let's just let's just find
out it is always funny though as every
time a new product has to come out it's
like Patriot water and some and some new
product stars and strip cereal
uh hey that's not a bad
idea I think it was Ryan long who did
that video where it's like leftwing
podcast sponsors versus rightwing patri
dirt the leftwing one was like we're you
know welcome to the anti-establishment
anti you know anti-government podcast
sponsored by Monsanto and then on the
right help yeah and on the right it was
like Patriot water it's water but for
Patriots and he's like and at the other
ones it was all MREs and and uh and
instant food leftwing podcasts all have
massive sponsors from McDonald yeah yeah
big corporations Ryan long doesn't miss
oh yeah no he had that really good one
about Israel Palestine that was that was
brilliant actor doesn't know who to
support and they were another one that
of his that's been going around again
recently is the winner he's like I sell
my I sell the footage to Fox and I sell
the footage to CNN M if you play it
backwards it looks fine no no he's like
I once sent p a video to Fox News of
protesters picking up litter and I said
don't worry if you play it backwards
they're lit maybe this is who the dis
campaign needs right to come in and be
like this is how you respond to Ashley
St Clair's boot thing they need a
Canadian to come in and fix it they need
some foreign Nationals Consulting
doesn't this is the point I made about
Trump is that here's that one clip where
he's like the lights they're too bright
they're making me look orange and
everyone busts out laughing you can't
make fun of trump because Trump's in on
the joke desantis's campaign doesn't get
that or they're intentionally sabotaging
him so they're just like don't make fun
of me you're stupid you're dumb it's
like wow that was none of it's Landing
none of it's sticking it's just his
campaign's over over I mean I think so
yeah I don't know but I will watch that
debate between him and N maybe Bud Light
can sponsor that debate yeah I'm more
interested in whether or not a UFC
fighter comes out and says yo what I
don't want to fight on you know what let
me text a few right now yeah we would
like some exclusive comments from them
on air that'd be great uh yeah I mean my
my question again goes back to contracts
like what are they allowed to say and I
would be interested if if in violation
of their contract potentially giving up
a lot of money they say something
anyways because I think that is what we
need people who are saying I don't like
this and I didn't forget why we were
boycotting budlight in the first place I
still remember why we were not buying
things at Target I mean that's the the
fact of the boycott they it's difficult
for them to last forever especially if
there's no alternative on the other hand
let's not forget why we went into them
in the first place it it it was earlier
this year we can't have seated the
ground so quickly is that a big part of
it though did is is in Dana White's mind
is the idea that they they waited like a
sufficient amount of time has passed and
and trying it now is not the same as
trying it in August or trying it in sep
sure I mean I don't think you would have
touched it in July right but on the
other hand uh I it makes me wonder about
the money and it makes me wonder about
his potential other dealings I think it
does not go well yeah there's no way
right this is gonna this is not I can't
wait now to get back home and be like
WTF what are you and all of these
Fighters that you know you can be like
Bud Light really gross yeah they already
hated it yeah so now are they going to
be forced to painted on their face like
where they walk out yeah Bud Light Flags
Bud Light cups they're going to it's it
we'll know couple weeks huge fight
Madison sore Garden mhm that's crazy
yeah we'll see what Strickland and
Covington and all those have to say
about it too because they've been pretty
pretty outright about their opinions so
they're not as Tim said they ain't
shutting up no definitely not I mean
unless they are made to shut up that's
that's what I come back to there are
always obligations where I mean yeah but
like these guys are just they don't even
they don't they don't care about the
cont trct here let's see what this UFC
fighter said oh my gosh breaking news
live on ktim C does he know you're on
air right now are we to oh no I'm not
going to say who it is but uh what what
the heck I just said we were having
breaking news what did they say the
fighters don't know about it and they're
pissed so they found out with everyone
else they are the Sophie Turner to Joe
John it's kind of like yeah how
apparently all big news breaks nowadays
you don't tell your own people you just
tell the this came out uh a couple hours
ago this news broke and wow it's a
Tuesday evening is like the the best
possible day for Bud Light it's maximum
PR day Tuesday Friday and Saturday
Saturday is like things get lost un
unheard of to release something on
Saturday Friday at 5 Friday at 5 is
where you bury it yeah but they like Bud
Light was like and we want you to
announced Tuesday evening this is a
great idea in the middle of a war in the
middle of you know he's like could we
soften it to Thursday at 10: they were
confident it was a Tuesday I just can't
imagine them can you imagine be like
this is a great idea Dana White says yes
and everyone will not not think about it
well they're they're just going to see
the power of UFC probably fade Just a
Touch here on this one because they
might have the Golden Touch but not not
the Bud Light Golden Touch it ain't
coming back I'm sorry a t i mean and the
thing about the Bud Light boycotts is
there are tons of people who work you
know in their breweries or whatever else
who were normal people who were swept up
in a national controversy that I'm sure
they didn't actually want to be a part
of right I mean this is Corporate
leadership betraying the actual
workers maybe budl can sponsor
Hamas so so you know I I I'll read I'll
read the super chats more in detail but
uh I'll just uh paraphrase one saying
that you know a lot of these Fighters
don't make a lot of money yeah Dana
White bringing bringing in this money
could help get these guys paid more and
I'm just like look if you're if you're a
pro doesn't make it to them if you've
got sponsors let's say you've got five
sponsors you've got companies a b c d
and e and then you decide to add on Bud
Light and now you have a big Bud Light
patch on your on your your jacket or
your pants or whatever those other
companies are going to be like dude dude
dude dude dude out we're done we're
we're cutting you off I mean look if if
like we sponsored something and then
someone decided to put Bud Light next to
it I'd be like no way dude like we don't
want to be associated with that we're
not going to sponsor if you're working
with with with them because it's just
like we don't agree with their values
it's bad across the
board that's a problem I'm wondering I
don't know how sponsorships works for a
work for a lot of these Fighters but
sponsorships are a big portion of how
athletes make money I assume it's the
same for UFC if if if they're now like
look man we don't we don't want to be
overlapping with Bud Light our audience
like let's say there's a jerky company
they're going to be like if people find
out that we're sponsoring this stuff
like we're going to lose money we just
we're better off sponsoring something
else no it's like 100 100 to 200,000 a
patch right on a short or something like
that and you have like two maybe three
right so yeah are you going to pull
those off to put budlight on and what is
budlight going to offer you or is the
UFC going to mandate that if you want to
fight in the UFC you have to have the
Bud Light logo on
your and that would force it and then I
don't think it's likely but there is a a
slim probability that there's a massive
backlash to UFC over doing this Bud
Light thing like you're mentioning
Fighters are pissed yeah I don't know to
what degree people actually care but
let's just operate under the assumption
there's a a big backlash I mean the
people screaming cheering for Trump are
going to be like boo it's going to be
gnarly and then if that does happen you
will get other sponsors going to UFC and
being like do not put our logo next to
light we like we we do not want to be a
part of whatever it is you're a part of
you do that that's fine is Dana White
risking losing other sponsors by doing
this deal with Bud Light I I I think so
I mean I just don't see how the Loyalty
brand that UFC has built up and whether
or not you think UFC's political you
have to just go to one of these events
and look at the people and talk to them
they are dialed in they are educated
they are more into the know about the
news and mainstream media then people
give them credit for because they're
like oh you guys just like fights
they're actually more dialed in than
anything else you can't get that kind of
reaction to anyone walking in unless
they know what the F's going on and and
they side with them like it's not like
they hate them in unison they went the
other way so if you fill a stadium full
of people with like that for your sport
I can't imagine the other people
watching it aren't feeling mostly the
same way in some form and especially
this the social media responses I saw
were for people who weren't there were
exactly the same way someone uh in the
regular chat said everyone has a price
Million Dollar Man even your mothers
have a price and that's just not true it
is not true that everyone has a price
most do most do um and that price could
actually be lower than people realize or
higher than people realize and uh I
wonder if that's just people have not
tried to sign deals before like there
are people with no price none and as
we've tried to hire and acquire you
learn 90 plus% of people in the space
there is no price you could buy them for
90 plus and I'm not talking about
compromising vales I'm talking about
we've gone to people who have like
moderate social media followings and
we're like would you want to like join
the timcast team and like we would help
distribute and market and they're like
no why I don't need it what am I going
to do with it and I'm like well like we
could we could help you make more money
we'll pay you more up front we'll then
seek ways to monetize we'll then try and
like we we'll we'll promote it and
they're like no thanks though mhm there
it's just like it's not hostile they
just don't need it right it's for a lot
of these people with social media and
the internet when they're making six
figures on their own already there is
nothing you can offer them because
they're like Freedom it's like I could
take a day off whenever I want I answer
to no one I've got good money for what
reason would I sign this deal and I'm
like you're right fa and for most people
deals offer security but if they feel
confident of they if they're established
enough like they don't they don't need
that either it's like being a small
business the challenge is most people
worth hiring are people who have proven
with a portfolio of their work and have
already found ways of monetizing it in
the modern era so I I I you know it's
not just that too but especially in the
world of political convictions you'll
find a lot of people are just unwilling
to do deals hey Bud Light had a price I
mean UFC had a price yeah I'm really
interested like all the MMA fighters
coming out being like no and which one
of them's going to be like 100 million
are you kidding me we we could have gone
for more yeah oh for real they could
have gone for more I bet I bet if they
went to Bud Light and says this is your
only chance you got to you got to make
it a billion dollars some ridiculous
number a billion over should have I
don't know what they were thinking over
the course over a period of time the way
they would do it is like a billion
dollars over 10 years or whatever I mean
maybe it's $100 million dollar for the
10 I like is there a dead brand and and
the $100 million you're seeing isn't
confirmed by the brands it's just
something you're seeing report online
right a bunch of news outlets have
reported a $100 million yeah all right
we're going to go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
friends and head over to
timcast.net says howdy people he got the
first Super Chat my row my local gun
shop says I am the winner no Jason T
says love you guys Soo howdy my local
gun gun shop follows up with no and
crying
emojis sorry man you didn't make it they
must be there at like 7:39 they are so
ready to go yeah finger on the trigger
kind of all right barely a millennial
says do you think these bizarre pramas
protests and rallies across the country
and the world are the result of years of
indoctrination or are they funded by
someone like Soros or someone some other
entity how do we expose it so it's a
combination you will find when you go to
these protest tests if you accuse these
people of getting paid by Soros they're
confused because none of them are but of
the 300 or 400 people you might see in a
protest there will be 10 who are paid by
a nonprofit which they don't realize
receives a large amount of funding from
the s from the uh open what is open
Society foundation and then uh what
they'll do is organize the protest
create a create an effort a viral effort
of tell your friends come this is when
we're doing it then when all these
people show up they're like what do you
mean we're not paid this is not a paid
event it was like this only exists
because open Society Foundation funded
nonprofits and Foundations which the
money trickles down to these NG these
nonprofit NGS which then hire people to
have them organize rallies that's how it
works
yep true all right IO Baka says hi all
longtime listener first-time super
chatter would cash consider becoming
Trump's
AG listen I'm I would I would say please
uh I the mission for me right now is
getting him elected that's my job so I
will work tirelessly until November of
next year to make that mission a reality
and I you know look I can share you this
I have a lot of conversations with him
but the one I had in private that I
thought was going to be like a
three-hour conversation maybe like a
year and change ago when we didn't know
what he was going to do and I was like
what the hell am I going to do you don't
know what you're going to do so I was
driving up to Bedminster and I was like
okay BOS I got like a you know I got the
afternoon like let's let's sit down and
jam what are you going to you know and
he goes cash I'm all in I go all right
I'm all in see you later shortest
meeting I ever had never look back and
um yeah we've talked about how Personnel
should be set in the next Trump
Administration it's a huge component of
my my book government gangsters like you
can't just replace the secretaries you
got to go down 15 rungs in every single
department at the White House every
agency I mean we have the list and I
have the list of an index in the book
that's why it's called government
gangsters there's an index from A to B
in the back of the book of every
government gangster that I ever
encountered by can I say a name yeah
it's published and so like uh you know
if he asked me to come back at a high
level position of course I'd go back but
would you want AG or would you want like
Chief of Staff I mean where where would
you want to be because they're very
different positions yeah look you have
to like the AG position works if you
have a great dag and a great FBI
director otherwise you're kind of
screwed you know you know or do you want
to go do ops or do you want to go take
on dood you know I've worked in both of
all three of those places and they're
all awesome you know it would be great
to have any of those jobs but you need
backing and so I hope another government
gangster doesn't slip through the cracks
and like another Rhino or uni party
clown shows up and says well yeah you
know I was rooting for you but I wasn't
really public about it so I'm going to
go hard to make sure more than anything
people don't get in yeah um because we
actually know the guys and gals that are
ready to go and if you're not hearing
their names in the mainstream media then
you kind of have your answer which uh
where there's an index of of the
gangster you said yeah it's in the back
of the book what like what page like
what would what like what am I looking
for cuz there's a lot it's just a list
of names in alphabetical order a list of
names yeah it's probably after that
section uh those are the those are the
there's end
notes maybe it's just before that I
should probably know that off the top of
my head I call the freaking book
government yeah cuz I'm I'm at the end
not it's like sources and citations yeah
so you got to go to uh page
215 appendix B members of the executive
branch deep state oh wow Story Time with
cash I love it look I mean I figured if
you're going to call him out you got to
freaking call him out that's the whole
point and it's nice to give people like
oh I've heard that name Bill bar well
right there's there's one for you John
Bolton but this is the thing people are
like oh this Trump guys writing this
book and I probably name more
Republicans than I do Democrats and the
point is it's not a it's not a political
Mission set they all get together to
destroy what I thought was a duly
elected presidency and in my opinion a
national security Mission and here we
are sitting in the remnants of that
right two tiers of Justice two more
Global Wars no security at the border
and China kicking our butts across the
world and the the you know Trump was
like okay everybody can write about
those problems and highlight these
people how do we fix it that's the core
concept of government gangsters like
every single agency Department can be
fixed but this is what you got to do
it's going to take a lift all right the
dungeon Delver says Tim please shout out
my D and group dungeon delver's group on
Twitch where a minitar mamasita means a
female one I appreciate all that you
guys do I didn't know that we like
Dungeons and Dragons It's a lot of fun D
and D Bud Light coming your way better
Ry actual says dude why are you letting
luk we change claim Ian like Princess
Peach and his super chats are going to
some weird scammy website just because
Florida has a beach drop him some dough
for his for his weak infrastructure and
brand it I have no idea what you are
what going on I like the idea Ian
doesn't have free will it's just like in
the video game Kim is of Our Lives yeah
we're all battling over Ian one big
simulation Ian just moves from place to
place wherever he's
[Laughter]
sent where are we
at thinker for Life says Cash There's a
huge opportunity for a Conservative
Business incubation Center in Michigan
it's a unique setup in a Battleground
Town it will go to liberals if we don't
I'm thinking for a life on Truth social
as well great Splash on Truth social and
let me know what your business idea is
I'll come see you nice then rru it do
you Miss Twitter at all are you happy on
Truth I've never been on Twitter or
insta or whatever the other ones are
called so you got social media only
because of trump you you want to know
influencer no you want to know how
hilarious it is I hate social media I
was never on it and then my former boss
leaves president and creates truth
social I still didn't get on then my
former former boss Deon Nunes becomes
the CEO of Truth social and so these two
guys call me and they're like oh yeah
this is going to be great I'm like yeah
good luck wish you all the success have
fun with social media MH and they were
like no you're on the board of directors
so you have to so I laughed out loud I
was like don't you want to hire somebody
who's actually signed on to Twitter
before I don't even know how to post
they like no you're a fresh perspective
and now now you know like 1.1 million
followers later here I am on it's a hell
of an elevator pitch no that's you know
it's it's a fun it's addicting and you
know you can you can make it an impact
all right Peter gohawk says in my
opinion these lawyers lives were
threatened and or families were
threatened by the Biden three-letter
agencies why else flip that quick fjb
perhaps perhaps that may be the case and
I get it I do uh and and that is an
issue but I suppose as I mentioned
before it is unfair to compare any of
these individuals to the founding
fathers who sacrificed their families
their children their loved ones their
sacred treasure to declare independence
to stand up against tyranny it's kind of
a crazy story the founding fathers
thought we would lose the war for
independence and signed a document
knowing they had just condemned
condemned themselves mhm that's crazy
yeah but they thought it was worth it
they had values that told them you have
to do this step and take this risk
anyways I think so I'm imagine these
guys are looking at each other like well
we are going to lose everything we own
we're going to die we can't win this but
it has to be done it's pretty ballsy
it's amazing it's it's what it's the
seeds that that are planted that lead to
a nation as great as the one we are as
as it has become no question I I assume
these people are facing a tremendous
amount of pressure it's a huge financial
burden to fight any government in this
type of ongoing lawsuit when they can
just continue to ask the taxpayers to
fund it on the other hand you have to
say their families knew what they were
advocating you know sometimes they have
you have to be the first one into the
fora and it's sad but you only have the
opportunity to stand up for what you
believe so many times in life and this
is the path they chose again I can't
imagine the pressure but it doesn't
change the fact that they said something
and now revoked it let's see neb says
Jenna's guilty plea is deferred not
filed as a judgment Rob Goa broke it all
down today the judge accepted it
deferred it and the case continues what
does that mean that just means she's on
probation and basically if you screw up
everything comes back that's not like
what do you know what so means well I I
don't think I could say that here no no
no statute of limitations oh is that
what it is yeah when I was uh uh 20
years ago I was in court the judge I was
arrested for skateboarding the judge uh
uh calls up my name is like next on the
dock whatever and uh he said the judge
looks at him he's like they call my name
I stand up and he's like what is this
and uh the prosecutor is like uh
skateboarding your honor and he's like
excuse me and they were like he was
skateboarding on on on State Property
downtown and he goes is this a joke and
he was like no and he goes he he just
like get in my courtroom he's like
you're not going to do it again get out
yeah and I was like I don't what does s
so mean like well the other one meant sh
out of luck but the but the statute of
limit he probably just needed a legal
excuse to be like oh yeah you should
have brought this it normally means you
have it have for every crime committed
there's supposed to be a number of years
you can bring that crime right if they
know about it and don't act eventually
it's gone and very few ones like murder
and terrorism don't have a statute of
limitations but but also people think it
means from the point of the crime but it
means from the point of Discovery right
well or when they should have known
about it right that you know if the feds
like are sitting on the document they're
like H well we just won't look at this
for 10 years it doesn't count you know
interesting but yeah that was basically
it what I what it was explained to me
that the idea was uh they could bring
the charges back at for some at some
point but they were saying to get out
they don't want to deal with it it was
stupid yeah it was uh uh there's a a
place in downtown Chicago sidewalk I was
skating on and they don't it was 3: in
the morning too with my friends and they
wanted to make an example because they
have a no skateboarding sign or whatever
but it's not illegal to skate and so the
judge was just like why are you wasting
the Court's time yeah it's ridiculous
there was some uh de that stuff happened
to us like when we were going downtown
like post 911 any government building
they were very quick to make an example
of you if you were skating on any type
of government property at that time
because they were very very uh try doing
that post 911 and being Brown yeah I
mean people do it all the time today
there's tons of videos on YouTube of
people skating in these same places with
no issue it's just you know is what is
all right where are we at Wayne Smith
says went and saw police state last
night first off cash amazing job in it
PS really puts in the perspective how
bad it's getting interesting it's not
good yeah taking back toxic says read
the 12th Amendment Trump and DeSantis
cannot run on the same ticket I've heard
that before but I've heard it disputed
as well so I don't know I mean but that
wasn't ultimately the reason that they
did not team up they're never going on
the same it ain't happening it's I'm
just it's it's not happening Bo 284 327
says did you see Preston parr's tweet
where he said he won the debate with you
he sounds like a grifter to me your
thoughts uh I don't consider it a debate
when one person says I hearby declare
thing the other person says what is your
evidence for thing and the other person
says I I hearby declare thing yeah I he
I'm like I wasn't I I I wasn't debating
with him that he was wrong I was asking
him what his proof was and when he
didn't have any I said this is just you
deciding you want this to be true I
don't care what your politics are uh so
this is the he he was arguing that he
thought Netanyahu knew Israel would be
attacked because Egypt issued a warning
then there was a 7-hour standown order
and I said okay what was the warning
that that Egypt issued we don't know
okay so it could have been anything it
could have been hezbollah's coming it
could have been from Jordan it could
have been from south from Sera who knows
so we don't know what that warning is so
there's very little to speculate on then
he said there's a s- hour standown order
and I said what's what's your source for
that right where is it a a guy who works
for an NGO in Israel who works with the
government said this and I'm like okay
single dubious source that doesn't
actually have privi information and then
it benefited Netanyahu and I'm like yeah
that's possible but highly speculative I
don't see the point of bringing it up
yeah so there's not really a debate it's
not look this is a big much bigger
conversation I wrote two op-eds on Intel
we didn't miss it we weren't looking
right that's how this all happens and
the same with the Israelis when you go
through woke woke policies as your
National Security priorities and you say
no we need to look at climate change in
the Setting Sun more than we need to
look at you know Terror that's literally
what this Administration has done and
then for them and they're going to come
and say this later they're going to be
like well there was this Intel analyst
who knew that was going to be attack
saying you have intelligence that Hamas
and Iran are going to attack Israel is
like saying America possesses
intelligence that the cartels are going
to bring in drugs to the
southern like if you don't empower the
people with the jobs to take them on it
doesn't freaking matter what you do you
know my thing is like uh uh there was a
reporting that Egypt warned Israel and
I'm like all the only quote we have was
something big and so imagine you get a
warning at your house or your business
that something big is coming what do you
do what do you do with that information
you hire security guards okay and then
guy parachutes onto the top of your
building and you're like I never would
have thought of that or he digs up from
under the floor I mean something big
could come from any direction it's just
impossible to say we don't know the
nature of the warning I'm like it's
possible but I think it's silly to be
like I want to debate it's like you know
what I I talked about it earlier today
what I'm calling Israel Palestine
derangement syndrome
Israel yeah IPS uh because we we we we I
mentioned this a little bit before the
show that no one cares about Mayan Mar
Burma since 19 48 hundreds of thousands
have been killed in this ongoing
conflict and uh uh even recently there's
tons of news and it's like there's
nobody nobody cares 12,000 people people
don't even know what a country or it is
no they don't yeah I made the joke I
said I'm I tweeted I'm going to get mad
about myar and someone said you mean
Burma and I'm like thank you you watch
Seinfeld yeah we're gonna we'll we'll
make this the new so it's like I
understand there's a religious component
but a lot of these people on the left
are advocating for Palestine for
literally no reason none whatsoever yeah
it's current thing the people who are
advocating for Israel typically have
families in Israel and however many of
these people have said very horrifying
things a former guest on the show
basically called for nuking Palestinians
like just killing everybody good idea no
it's insane so it it is very very heated
I can understand why someone like
benjiro is very upset he has family
there he was just there I respect that I
don't understand why your random college
leftist is chanting in support of Hamas
and I'm like you don't know anything
about the region there's no reason I
don't I don't get it no they're doing it
cuz it's a cool thing to do it's po
it's in Rolling Stone you have to you
know go wearing a mous shirt
or oh yeah that's a great idea J gar let
him give me that Jason Hutchinson says
this is good the Republican party needs
to end it has been either ineffective at
preventing what's happening today or
complacent with it I mean we complicit
yes and people are like are we should we
be happy about having a speaker and I'm
like this is a good thing I mean it's
definely keeping us from sending money
abroad right now that's yeah what's
what's what's the argument if we had a
speaker we be funding more Wars just so
having gone through a government
shutdown and being denied getting paid
and being in one of the few jobs that
actually never got their money back I'm
like the one of the like
0.00000000 1% of people ever impacted by
government shutdown who watching this
show or anyone that you know is actually
impacted by a federal government
shutdown other than the mainstream media
to lay political blame VI benefits is is
the is the main
concerns I got it the troops and all
that stuff I got it there's money in the
coffers to fund that stuff it doesn't
run out because the government turns off
that is a bogus DC government fiction um
that they scare us into with oh my God
the world's going to end remember in the
Obama Administration the government shut
down for months month
months and I was a federal public
defender and they named my small crew of
people non-essential so I never got paid
back but every other government employe
got retroactive pay for the entire time
once the government turned on so I don't
want to hear it so so when when is this
uh the current CR supposed to expire no
oh shoot I should know that three or
four weeks three or four weeks they
don't get a speaker in three or four
weeks there's just government shut down
yeah all right Tim's like do it do every
libertarian is like going like yeah I'm
not I'm not so much you know I'm not so
adamant about it I think Matt Gates
makes interesting points we don't want
people to go without pay and I get that
a lot of people live paycheck to
paycheck I got it and I don't want them
to do it but what's the altern if we
just keep pring funding to these
lobbyists and and and massive
corporations oh they are I don't they
are having a dance party in DC the
defense industrial complex and the
lobbyists are turning it on oh there
this $500 billion doll machine you just
gave like fentanyl to with you know like
ecstasy in it or something I don't even
know what those two do but these guys
are going out there buying Democrats and
Republicans $100 billion check to you
you get 10 million you get 1 million get
us this next B DOD contract the world is
ending we have to make new Munitions and
weapons and missiles and they're like
this is our
Co essentially big Pharma right madna
and fizer now there's a big five in the
dod industrial complex space let's go
they're like let's go and you know the
guys that are running these companies
the government gangsters that used to be
the Secretary of Defense the chairman of
this Secretary of the army all get paid
we got a Super Chat the other day a
couple people mentioned this that
there's like some uh Ammunition Company
the company that makes ammo that
switched entirely to government
contracts instead of Civilian that's a
Nob brainer I'm not super right but uh
uh I'm not super familiar maybe someone
in the chat knows but this is indicative
of of War mhm well no what it is
indicative of is getting paid so when
you get on a when you get on a
government what we call goo a government
funded Prime contract a PR you are set
for life especially if it's in the
defense industrial complex space those
are very hard to get and they don't pay
you for like a year they pay you for
like 15 budget C
and they usually pay an inordinate
amount so government contract supposed
to go to like the lowest bidder who can
do it best but what we end up doing is
delay delay delay then paying the
highest guy because we want to screw
over the other guys because we were too
slow in getting it right in the first
place all right soy solra says family
dog just passed away today he was very
loving very fluffy and very short rest
in peace shorty I will love and miss you
it was an amazing 16 years 16 years a
long time that's good sorry to hear it
but uh rest in peace shorty shorty
shorty Kane able says you think the
government cannot write checks due to
not having a speaker they will do it
behind closed doors in
private but Biden can stroke checks true
yeah Edward M says ug WTF the UFC signed
a deal with anheiser
bush don't get started cringe so many
weird things have happened this year you
know it's definitely not what I would
have seen coming still we got two and a
half months left Phil Jame Philly James
says as a regular UFC Watcher I couldn't
tell you the sponsor from this last
Saturday fight don't care about still
watching the fights yeah
see Matt Allen says I canceled my UFC
Fight Pass subscription today I bet
you'll get some from each of those camps
right some so the people who are I mean
that even that person is who is clearly
politically aware because they're
watching this show and still values the
the entertainment over that there's no
alternative right like you could say I'm
going to buy another beer but you're not
going to watch a different fight
especially now they what you going to go
watch power slap yeah yeah hey go do
that you go that is wild it's crazy Seth
weathers says those mfers beat us by 100
million million to be the official UFC
beer sponsor brutal imagine if UFC
decided just to go with ultra right
conserv Dad ultra beer and they were
just like I mean because you could
theoretically do it1 million they say
right you could theoretically uh Seth
could do the same deal and it's based
off contingency it's like we'll do a
$100 million deal which basically means
once we sell up to that number it all
goes to you and then afterwards it goes
back to us yeah totally interesting yeah
yeah yeah you can find some venture
capitalist rich guy who's totally on
board the anti- bush light whatever
Budweiser train and be like I'll give
you the check we'll make our own
fighting league for MMA you just want
Jeremy to get in this space
Jeremy Tim cast logger we need the
Jeremy signal it's like a light in the
sky and it signifies Jeremy that a
company's gone woke is an opportunity
for a business
venture I think he he's only done two
right I mean technically no he's doing
the Snow White movie too right right
this is you know but but it's funny
because like Theos basically there is a
clear path of success that's been proven
and they've abandoned it so all Jeremy
is doing is being like I'm getting back
on the path like Snow White is a huge
success they've made a crappy version
I'll make it and then I'll get rich like
right they don't care about selling it
it it's it's a proven money making
Venture and they've abandoned it I'll
take it he's going to have to open the
daily wire store right next to Target
yeah it's like Congress for Hollywood
yeah I mean yeah like where's where's
Jeremy's grocery yeah could you imagine
like 100 years from now it's like
literally everything is just like Public
Square is one company it's Jeremy's
everything no it's terrifying I don't
like that either that's too much for me
Isn't the Aldi's guy pretty base though
he's like a hyper capitalist and he's
yeah yeah Aldi and ALDI is one of the
top organic roaches there used to be one
of the top organic grocers in the US I
remember he did the thing with Rogan
where he's like oh these people they
don't understand how money
works okay Boomer Dad thank you I'm just
kidding what do we got beef nasty says
UFC is going to take Bud Light Money and
Run UFC fighters will rag on budlight
and they won't care if a fighter brings
ppv's money and daddy Dana don't care if
they smack talk
budlight that's what I'm saying how many
people are going to be like so what free
money they're going to get made fun of
BU light's going to it's going to hurt
Bud Light more because now everyone's
going to make fun of them yeah they
can't and they obviously cannot abandon
their hyper masculine brand that's what
they have learned through all of this
yeah unfortunately that's a win for men
good job
guys I'm betting it
tanks yeah more likely kcb says Trump's
lawyers trading their principles because
they've never had to weigh them Against
the Machine if they went to prison and
probone a legal services for everyone in
the prison they'd be out in 6 months
their strength and
weakness you know it's like it's it's
it's that that that line for mighty
mighty ball Stones I'm not a coward I've
just never been tested I'd like to think
that if I was I would pass MH these
people were tested and they all failed
everyone of them I can't believe there
was a Mighty Mighty Boss Tones
reference well I mean come on like you
know Dicky is in the band with he's he's
with Pete Pata and the defiant now so
like Mighty B Boston is back in the
playlist baby let's go yeah listen to
dead language by the defiant that song's
great it's uh it's about just like
society's become so brutal and no one's
paying attention anymore they're on
their phones yeah good song five times
August was on was on our show last week
and after the release of this new single
which is basically calling out all the
musicians who shielded for big Pharma
and that was Friday too right yeah and
that was actually the day we had the
music all set up we could have totally
had him come up in jail complete uh
inter office
commun have to work on that come on
Brett that's all right all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends but head over to
timcast.net you want the answers they're
in here the government receipts are in
here the gang are here how many how many
books do you need to sell to pledge to
to become the AG uh 100,000 let's go is
that it yeah okay it's a tough book
Market I'm already a bestseller in Wall
Street Journal and Amazon New York Times
were like oh you sold enough books to be
a bestseller but we're not putting your
book on so so the point is you can't
make yourself AG but you know so it's
not really something you can guarantee
but if you sell 100,000 of these books
you will pledge to do everything with
your power to become the AG o maybe
200,000 I think you want a different
position that's my new Theory well you
might be on a some we can talk later but
yes thank you bye government gangsters.
comom yeah by the books also hard copy
books are great and we're going up into
you know Christmas and stuff so gift it
to everyone you know uh I'm Hannah Clair
brimo I'm a writer for
timcast.net
on Instagram on Twitter whatever they
are these days I don't know if we're on
Truth social maybe got to get on join
the party um and if you want to follow
me personally I'm on Instagram at han.
and I'm on Twitter or X HC brimo thank
you guys so much and also Brett's here
oh yes yes guys uh if you want to follow
me you can follow me on Instagram and
Twix at Brett dvic on both of those
platforms pop culture crisis is live
Monday through Friday 3 pm Eastern
Standard Time noon Pacific come on uh
come hang out with me and Mary it's a
lot of fun and I am surge.com newly
minted on Truth social verified yeah
apparently cat will verify me so follow
me on true social I'm on and all the
other sites as well uh yeah see you
there we will see you all over at
timcast.net